all right welcome everybody um earlier
start and a bit of a different day today
this is day nine in the kyle rittenhouse
trial uh the defense has rested and so
today what we are going to see the jury
won't be in today
and it is going to be a discussion and
presumably a final decision about the
instructions that the judge is going to
give the jury and this is this is really
not only is it not trivial
this is arguably one of the most
important things i i told the story by
the way we've already banned eight
people and i've been on for for 30
seconds there were people getting banned
before and people continuing to get
banned now it's actually crazy it's
humiliating what what the
clingers have done uh who are who are
following this trial on my channel for
some reason it's crazy
um i told the story of my jury duty
and it was a it was a case about
self-defense actually not with a death
but with a physical attack
and um
we
were given specific instructions as to
what self-defense means by the law
and
two-thirds of the jurors
not me of course two-thirds of the
jurors were going by their belief about
what self-defense is and so this is not
trivial this is a really really big
thing and then monday
the closing statements are going to take
place uh two and a half hours per side
have been allotted including the
prosecution's rebuttal
and um
by roughly two three in the afternoon
local time the jury will start to
deliberate
and then we will see right and then we
will see so um
that's the plan scheduled to start in a
few minutes we're going to be covering
all of it while we wait for people to
connect i do have other things i want to
go over and i have a bunch of clips
related to the judge and and a lot of
different things
um
we are i i'm gonna play a voicemail that
i've not listened to
but i can see that it contains extreme
profanity and explicit language so i'm
gonna warn people ahead of time if you
have kids watching right now or whatever
i'm about to play a voicemail that seems
to contain very very uh disgusting
attacks on me
it's not from whitney
so i'm warning everybody i'm warning
everybody i'm about to play it i'm about
to play it i'm about to play it okay
let's listen this is us listening
together
you're a [ __ ] little [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucker [ __ ]
eat a [ __ ] dick
saw some knives
[ __ ] you
okay
so there is the voicemail that i warned
everybody about elements of bathrooms
so um we're going to have to try to
flush that message 10 or 15 times
um
[Music]
it will be it will be a report yeah yeah
we report all of those and sometimes you
know what's crazy i mean someday i will
tell these stories
but sometimes some someone who is
actually on the radar of law enforcement
will leave a voicemail
and the fact that they don't block their
number will lead to things things that
happen and i have i have stories that i
could tell you would be shocked at the
stories i could tell you
let's put it that way
um what else do we have here
eggman commenting on 41 month sentence
for one of the trump writers hey dave 41
months for assaulting a police officer
at the capitol is definitely not enough
however the guys that think that 41
months is too much all this guy should
have done is taken an assault rifle shot
a couple people murdered them and then
claimed he feared for his life and he
definitely would have got no time kyle
rittenhouse is completely getting off
and 41 months for assaulting a police
officer i saw the video is nothing those
people that protested the blm in
minneapolis and seattle i looked up some
of those uh sentences okay they're way
more than 41 months and they didn't hit
cops it was for like property damage and
arson but a skateboard smashing shallow
brother this is [ __ ] you know it
shalom and shabbat shalom coming very
very soon i am going to be picking up a
khala bread
imminently imminently elements of holla
because tomorrow i am making chala
french toast and it's going to be it's
going to be crazy actually so shabbat
shalom everybody
um let's see what else we've got here
um
let's do one eric from mass he's calling
daily now
hey david it's eric from maps um i've
got to start to think that these
mounting lives are deliberate uh
i have video more than happy to send it
to you
um
you know
i don't know if i check your email let
me know somehow or whatever but uh
i'm more than happy to show it to
another lie so hey is that the actual
tyt sports account who likes the holla
french toast
reference i think it might be
is that actually there's a check mark
next to it that's great if the tyt
sports guys are here welcome everybody
whoever it is that's here with that
account
um
okay i do have uh thanks to small fuzzy
moss i now have in my sound board
a bunch of different audio elements from
judge schroeder and people people might
like these let's take a listen to what
we've got
whatever you do make sure you go to the
bathroom somewhere other than the
carpool right that was on the first day
when the judge was kind of explaining
the ground rules
and one of the ground rules was do not
go to the bathroom in the courtroom or
in the jury box that he did not want
that i've got a bunch of the food
related ones by the way how are the
calzones
the food is here
let's take a break lunch is here
pizza is here
but uh we have subway tomorrow right so
the judge really really wrapped up with
um with the different lunch elements and
then we do have the pickles quote as
well uncharged piccolos
i still think my favorite is calzones
by the way how are the calzones
man
uh okay so we have those in our arsenal
now
for moving forward which i think is a
really important thing let's see some
super chats are coming in kimmy says
pacman come to finland yes i've been to
finland i was in helsinki i was i was
really all over that uh that country and
i loved it um as many of you know
there's this salmon soup that is quite
common for my family soup for my family
which i had in finland excellent
excellent soup um
really hard to beat it quite frankly
pizza is here good morning thanks for
covering the trial if the world was
saying kyle would become a proponent of
gun regulation safety so no other kids
end up in the same position as him yes
all good points all good points
um okay i have a few other things folks
let's look at some of these few other
things first we have new memes i don't
know if you noticed but yesterday there
was a moment where um people were
looking at a screen so people started
sending me these at one point this is
judge schroeder and the entire
legal team
trying to figure out the legality of my
hair on a prior stream and as you can
see some of these images are compressed
vertically some are compressed
horizontally there were questions as to
whether the pickles were different
colors in these images and which of
these would be admissible to the jury so
they were looking at that very very
closely
um
they had another
let's see here's another one
this one here the judge was made aware
by one of the bailiffs that during his
trial we were offering what could be
illegal discount codes on memberships in
kenosha
and the judge went over and looked at it
very closely and as you can see the
coupon code up in the air
raising
many many many problems
in that courtroom
the defense attorney in particular was
disgusted hands on his hips and just
couldn't believe we got busted yesterday
but we're still offering the code today
so that's what it is we added pixels to
the discount and then also at another
point that this was an example of where
when you zoom in it looks completely
different although it looks like the
zoomed area is someone holding a firearm
when they zoomed in the pickles changed
and it was actually a pickle that was
the man was holding not a gun
and so this was really the source of the
controversy when it came to zooming and
algorithms logarithms exponents
uh the mnemonic please excuse my dear
aunt sally for the proper order of
operations that we all learned in middle
school
um
the the only thing is they were charged
pickles they were not uncharged pickles
uncharged piccolos
so that was that
all right everybody um so that's uh
that's the latest there
let me see what else we have
not only was the issue brightness and
contrast as some people in the chat are
saying another issue was actually um
saturation and
hue how saturated were the pickles with
dill
how saturated were they were they
actually bread and butter pickles which
is my preference so all questions that
are going to be answered at some point
very very soon
gamer pigeons asking where's the hot
food soundboard element our
soundboard engineer small fuzzy moss
um apprised me that they're looking for
hot food
and they're gonna have it over to me
very very soon so we're standing by for
that
uh let's see tyt sports asking david do
you put cinnamon on your challah french
toast i sometimes will add a little bit
of cinnamon and nutmeg
um sometimes not you really you know
it's one of those things where you
really don't need it if you have a good
challah
and um you've got your your egg milk
batter you know the thing i don't do is
a lot of people add sugar
to the
french toast
batter for lack of a better term
although can it really be called batter
if there's no flour i don't know that'd
be maybe kenji could answer that
question for us but i don't i don't do
sugar because later i'm adding maple
syrup i don't need sugar and maple syrup
i know that you know in other part parts
of the country they do that but
i i don't i don't find myself needing to
it's custard okay i don't find myself
needing to add sugar now kenji will tell
you
if you want it crispier you can add
sugar
um
i
maybe it's something about the pan i'm
using
i don't it's crispy even without it it's
crispy even without it
um
yeah nutmeg and cinnamon i don't i don't
even do vanilla either
i don't even do juvenile i don't need it
some people you know adding vanilla
extract once i i read on the internet
and i don't even know if this is allowed
someone using almond extract for french
toast and i thought that's got to be at
least against federal law if nothing
even if states allow it been watching
you since the elections last year great
show great commentary greetings from
hungary hey um oh this is actually a
really good question shane wants to know
should the jurors have had stromboli
rather than
uh calzones i think that's a fair
question by the way how are the calzones
yeah
um yeah the trial is a parody of itself
i don't i don't know
what saturday night life could even do
with it tomorrow night we'll see oh yeah
i did get um i got my third dose
yesterday i got my third shot
um i woke up so i got it at 4 30
p.m
my time zone i don't know what time i
mean okay it was 1 30 on the west coast
but i don't think it matters i'm not on
the west coast today
um
i got it at 4 30
i woke up at let's see when i went to
bed at 11
my arms started to hurt
and
i was awoken at 5 00 a.m
and i just didn't feel great but it
wasn't like too bad
um i eventually woke up for good at 7 30
and i wasn't feeling great it it's
basically like with my first and second
dose just not quite as bad
and um
i had a
i had a tylenol with breakfast and i'm
feeling okay right now i took my
temperature not i feel a little feverish
i'm not running a fever
uh
but it's we're looking into the immune
response pretty strongly yep very much
so
alan says as a southerner who was told
by a michigan writer that they have no
accent this is all very delightful for
me yeah i mean guys come on you know uh
whatever you do make sure you go to the
bathroom somewhere other than the
carpool the bathroom
also
every time they talk about the fires
basically it's like fire but you just
keep your mouth closed that's the way i
do it fire
fire
the fires they set a fire
um no there's quite an accident there
it's almost canadian in a way and i
think that it's actually i think that in
states like wisconsin and northern
michigan etc they refer to some of these
um
you know idiosyncrasies
as canadian raising have you guys heard
that term before
check out my interview on these accents
with william labov
i know it's not canadian i'm saying it
goes in that direction and there's a
geographical proximity to canada as well
minnesota as well yeah
the foyers yeah it's like wait a second
they set a house foyer they went into
your foyer and they set it on fire the
foyer was on fire it's crazy it's crazy
it's probably the reason they didn't
even have stromboli i don't think anyone
would know what they meant if they
pronounced stromboli with a kenosha
accent i think that's probably the
explanation okay let's get into some
other things i do have other things i
wanted to go over with you guys here
first of all there was a moment where
there was a standing ovation yesterday
in the courtroom and we didn't know what
it was now look at the check the the
defense attorney is doing the tucker
carlson face which is great
apparently what happened is yesterday
was veterans day and the judge said are
there any veterans here it turns out the
only veteran in the room was the next
defense witness so there ended up being
a standing ovation for a defense witness
do you think that taints the jury's
opinion of that witness when the judge
demands a standing ovation so let's take
a look at that oh i wanted to just
observe
that it's
veteran state
and any veterans on the road on the jury
or anywhere else
well that's unusual not to have at least
somebody in here but dr black is
at what branch
okay and uh i think we give a round of
applause to the people who served
can you imagine okay so you may proceed
oh my god so it's like the only the only
veteran who they cheer for is the next
witness for the defense just everything
everything about it
um i am gonna on monday do a pretty deep
dive into the uh
interview that rittenhouse's mommy did
last night with hannity
and i've said before that the entire
rittenhouse thing whatever you think
about the actual charges which again i
think it's going to be not guilty for
self-defense
this is not only a failure of gun
culture it's also a failure of parenting
because as i said before there is no way
it would even occur to me when i was 17
that it would be remotely plausible to
consider
thinking about exploring the possibility
of maybe going armed
to defend properties against riots right
okay so
we said part of this is the parenting
um and if you watch the interview with
his mommy
you will see that it's
clearly this is a failure of parenting
when the then candidate now president of
the united states
and other elected officials
that don't know anything about your son
refer to him as a white supremacist
i have yet to see any evidence
whatsoever that he is such a person
when the then the candidate so it was a
very softball interview sorry i have to
keep banning people
um
man we've already banned 20 people and
we haven't even really started so okay
the one question hannity should have
asked here is
what were you thinking as a mother
dropping your son off with a gun to
defend property as a kid
and getting him into this mess to begin
with shouldn't you as a mother have said
kyle this is dangerous and insane and
you're not going
that's the one question that should have
been asked it wasn't asked okay
um now if you
i mean look
would kyle have done it again yeah he
would have done everything the exact
same way
have you and your son discussed
whether or not if he had to do it over
again he would go into a situation like
that first of all had to do it over
again why would he have to the entire
thing was optional
with kyle
i know him and he probably would do it
again because that's the type of person
he is
he always wants to help people
who did who did he help
who did he help
um
i mean just an indictment on the
parenting crisis of of the united states
of america
here's just one more clip and we'll have
a full review on this this
this is a disastrous parenting element
right
that's your son
how did that make you feel
it just
i just broke down with with kyle crying
like that
it made me feel heartbroken
sad
and i wanted to just go up there and
just hug him
and tell him it would be okay
oh man it's just it's it's bad very very
bad
i mean just none of this makes any sense
none of it makes any sense and and
listen in seeing the interview with the
mom
it explains to us a lot of this
situation now working to if you're gonna
come through my chat and say things like
kyle is a hero you're getting banned
you're just getting that's it you're
getting banned we're just not gonna
allow that stuff you can have a view
about guilt or innocence or whatever
um but you things like kyle is a hero
um here's another one kyle took out the
antifa trash you're banned
um
what else do we have here i mean it's
just the number of bands it's it's crazy
actually how many people are getting
banned
soy rage pacman is a ban
um
here's another kyle as a hero which is
getting banned
what else
man it's it's sad to have to ban this
number of people you know
it really is
okay
all right good um let's see
kyle is a hero free the kenosha kid so
let's see let's hide that user they're
banned i appreciate the money dana oh is
this the same person dana mcwhite says
failure of parenting what about all the
guilty lies and misinformation you
spread about kyle i think your parents
failed oh they're already banned okay
good
um
vic judge victim is too strong a word
for me so the domestic terrorist killed
the american citizens
i would never take my son to a thing
like this but as a canadian
lb dab to get the whole gun craze jesus
i don't know what that's about
okay
all right good um
[Music]
all right welcome everybody today is a
crucial day crucial day and we're
standing by for the judge right now
there's a little bit of disagreement as
to whether they are 15 minutes late or
45 minutes early right now but we're
gonna stand by for all of it and as as
we are doing right now the judge is
going to um finalize the instructions to
the jury in other words what is the
basis on oh sorry hold on a second i got
to ban more people
um
beta male [ __ ] person is getting banned
who else are we banning here
let's go brandon is a band
uh very this is actually great we're
bringing out so many obvious trolls
that um
we're able to ban this is actually
really good
are there any mods in the chat
yeah let's temporarily go over to
member only chat so now at least you're
going to have to pay to troll
i do want to thank folks we are now on
this is trial day 9 meaning the 10th day
because there was also the jury
selection which we're not counting as
one of the days
um i really appreciate folks who have
been supporting these streams we are
down to the last day remember if we get
to 50 members today
the mustache not only stays
i will darken it i've committed to
darkening it not black because i don't
have black hair i will darken it in a
way
that matches my hair
for monday for the monday stream i will
be here for closing arguments with a
filled in mustache okay that's what's on
the
agenda for today
so
first of all i would love for you to
sign up at joinpakman.com just because
you want to support the work that we're
doing
but as an extra incentive we have the
mustache has survived each day and if it
survives today i've committed monday i
will be here with
the darkened mustache and i predict it's
going to be quite a quite a scene
it could get us kicked off the air i
don't know it could get us kicked off
the air but we're going to we're going
to look at that and monitor it very very
strongly all right let me refresh a few
things we already looked at because
not all of you have seen them we got
some great memetic elements
at one point the entire pixel
controversy led to the judge wanting to
get a really close look at pictures of
my hair to see if it was
uh honest and truly represented in these
images or whether it had been compressed
modified uh desaturized saturized
saturated i don't know uh hue
enhancement or different things the
judge also did not feel that pinch was
appropriate during some of these moments
also other versions of this that people
sent which were really good
the coupon code at one point the judge
concerned it may be illegal
and he wanted to get a really close look
at the coupon code we were
using during his during his trial he
wants to run a clean trial and felt that
up in the air was just a little bit too
aggressive sir your wife is up in the
air and then at another point they were
looking at a picture which when zoomed
and enhanced
changed what looked like a firearm into
a pickle
and uh he didn't like that uncharged
piccolos right
um
okay
so that's that we looked at that we also
kicked off the show with maybe one of
the most aggressive voicemails i've ever
received
you're a [ __ ] little [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
eat a [ __ ] dick
saw some knives
[ __ ] you
right
um all right um on the assumption that
the trolls have calmed down a little bit
we're gonna go back to just regular chat
mode
um
and i very much uh
very much appreciate that
okay a couple other things for you
um i didn't actually realize that
yesterday when the judge mentioned the
thing about the asian food which they
were getting for lunch yesterday that he
also made a political comment about the
supply chain i didn't i didn't even
realize it but that's exactly what he
did so let's take a listen to that uh
let's hope for one o'clock i don't know
the uh hope the asian food isn't coming
it's on isn't on one of those boats in
long long beach harbor
right so this is a reference to
the shipping containers on boats
in long beach harbor
supposedly because of joe biden and
because pete boot edge edge was on
paternity leave
so
completely inappropriate comment for the
judge to be making i mean it's just kind
of like a wtf moment
uh really really weird and then here is
just a tot this is a different trial
this was in the ahmad arbury trial
and in the admob arbory trial
the defense attorney
objected to the fact that
there are black pastors coming in and
sitting with ahmad arbury's family
i don't know what the race of the
pastors
what role the race of the pastors plays
now you guys all know i'm no fan of al
sharpton or jesse jackson whose name
comes up
their history of anti-semitic comments
and all these different things i i'm
just not i don't care about al sharpton
or jesse jackson one way or the other
they're not interesting political
figures to me
but this is a crazy comment we don't
want black pastors coming through here
what over 100
and
the idea that we're going to be
seriously bringing these people in to
sit with the victim's family one after
another
obviously there's only so many pastors
they can have and in fact their pastor's
al sharpton right now that's fine but
then that's it we don't want any more
black pastors coming in here
jesse so
it looks like this woman sort of
has a reaction but tries to contain it
we don't want any more black pastors
just watch this woman very closely let's
see if we can even zoom it in maybe
uh here we go
here we go that's fine but then that's
it we don't want any more black pastors
coming in here
jesse jackson whoever was a man here
earlier this week sitting with the
victim's family trying to influence a
jury in this case and i'm not saying the
state is even aware that mr sharpton was
in the courtroom i certainly wasn't
aware of it until last night but i think
the court can understand
my concern yes about bringing people in
who really don't have any ties to this
case other than political interests
right
so
quite a guy huh quite a guy
so the um
they don't they don't want any more this
isn't a revolving door of black pastors
guys give me a break
uh okay
martin says i've been watching your
coverage for a while i appreciate the
work you've done wondering how many
times the judge of this trial will
interrupt the prosecutor's closing
statements that's a good question hot
food coming need to interrupt
i actually prefer charged pickles thanks
for the coverage david it made for an
interesting week uh my pleasure jamie
and it will continue next week sorry to
hear about twitch hope this helps i know
a membership is better but i'm already a
member thanks for all you do very much
appreciate that
and a bunch of people dumping in youtube
memberships here the mom's response in
the interview almost made her sound as
sympathetic to kyle rittenhouse as the
judge yeah
the dgg bridge is shaky right now but
there is a fix we need obama
obama
um david sir we should watch the ahmad
arbury trial for comparison on what a
normal judge acts like yeah is the is
that actually going on right now because
we might actually be able to pick up a
few minutes of that
uh oh yes
oh but it's in recess
okay let's pull it up because it
actually is the so i'm not saying that
everything's going swimmingly in the
ahmad arbury trial but at least the role
of the judge is not humiliating and
pathetic so we're going to keep an eye
on both of these i'll keep the volume up
so that when they resume we'll see it
and then uh they're in recess until 10
30. okay so they'll be back in seven
minutes that's great that's great
what are the coupon codes today okay
there's uh there's endless coupon codes
available coupon code up in the air is
available coupon code felony21 is
available coupon code sad trump is
available i believe that coupon code
cucked no more
is also available
um
do we want a pickles coupon code i think
it might be the day for it if there's
any day for it let's see
let me see if uh will uncharged pickles
work
uncharged pickles
coupon code uncharged pickles for big
discount goes off the edge let's see if
for discount would work
for
no
i think i can just do i mean people will
know it's a discount code right
uncharged pickles to save there we go
okay so let me now put in the coupon
code here coupons
oh bom no no i'm gonna say i want to
save the coupon code obama for 2022
when the when hopefully obama is
actually campaigning for people
okay uncharged
pickles
make sure i'm spelling it correctly
um let's see oh hold on sorry
i gotta ban another one of these kyle is
a hero people
you are banned permanently banned
all right and let's make it a 69
discount
first person to use the code uncharged
pickles gets a free item from my uh web
store all right i'm putting it out there
right now coupon code is
live my friends coupon code is live okay
new coupon code is uncharged pickles
uncharged pickles there you go
and it is live and it is working
first person to use it gets a free item
or an item as we might call it
a thanks to vincent adkins for signing
up on my website but with a different
coupon code not uncharged pickles the
offer for uncharged pickle still stands
let's look at a few other super chats
here
what do we have coming in i worry about
kyle copycats after the verdict i worry
about it as well absolutely would be
awesome to see brian tyler cohen as a
guest you two doing a collaboration
could bring massive dumps of subscribers
for each other i like the
idea is there any reason you're covering
written house but not arbory written
house started earlier and i can't cover
both and you know we'll do what we can
but it seems as though this one is kind
of wrapping
and
we'll we'll shift over to the ahmad
arbory case next week assuming it's
still going i have no problem doing that
no problem doing that
mocking president trump's video for
celebrating beloved veterans that's one
more video you've made about our troops
severe case of trump derangement syndra
whackman i like i actually like the fact
david wackman has now spent about
probably 150 bucks
on super chats just to criticize me uh
which is fine
um
okay it looks like we've got more people
to ban here
dave had been listening to the show for
a year love the show and the content i
followed the trial gotta get that
horseshoe mustache whoa
what are your thoughts on pickle soaked
in root beer and or kool-aid i'm against
it very very strongly against it coupon
code 45 is the new zero hi david were
you able to review the lies the
prosecution caught kyle and i believe he
lied about being issued a bulletproof
vest and attending congress uh college
yeah i did actually get to review it let
me see if i can find that video
uh let's see what we got here
rittenhouse vest
college let's see if i can find that
okay here we go yep so this is this is
something yesterday what about even
going with perjury all right i mean here
we go
well we're working to see if we get
witness it'd be a
person from the grayslake police
department to
rebut the fact that mr rittenhouse was
issued a
bullet-proof vest by them they indicated
they did not issue him one
also i can't imagine we find someone but
the
arizona state or whatever university
that the defendant claims to be
attending
says he is not enrolled there and is not
going to college there i don't imagine
getting a witness for that for me of
course okay yeah so there was there was
the explanation as to what they're
looking to do
and uh that's really going to be i i
don't know what role that will play
there were people saying well just you
know charge him with perjury unlikely
unlikely but certainly conceivable
certainly conceivable
love the show homie
tucker charged pickle army 2024
exactly okay the first person to use the
coupon code
uncharged pickles
earning themselves a free item
from my webstore is william woodruff who
is also new member number two today
uncharged piccolos other new members i
want to welcome
elliott mckinley has signed up using
that code
nate jimenez used uncharged pickles
kirby harding is a new member wilfredo
flores
samuel kaplan is a new member
noah capp sales that's one two three
four five six new members using the
coupon code uncharged pickles uncharged
piccolos that puts us at eight
other folks oh wow
this is crazy juan salazar is a new
member carrie sander has signed up
daniel petro is a new member nicholas
shaffer is a new member and michelle
cooper michelle we love you here all
signing up using the coupon code
uncharged pickles uncharged piccolos
jumping us right out to 13 i see people
asking are we doing double patreon today
let's do it let's do it all it's the
last stream of the week let's do it if
you make a pledge at patreon.com david
pakman show instead of counting as one
it will count as two
we're throwing everything at it
uh people asking how i'm feeling after
my third dose so listen i i did tweet
about this
earlier i hope people are following me
had my third covid vaccine yesterday
awoke with arm pain
headache and aches
full disclosure i almost tripped coming
out of the pharmacy due to a slippery
broken sidewalk area do i need to report
that i almost tripped minutes after
getting the vaccine in the vaers system
does anybody know whether that's a
vaccine-related
event that should be reported
does anybody know it should be reported
okay
okay
wow
it should be reported yeah
people asking why i'm eligible give me a
break guys come on uh no in all
seriousness
um i am in a situation where i am at
risk of transmitting covid to an
immunocompromised person
um and also with some significant travel
coming up i qualify as being both at
risk of transmitting and getting covered
uh because of where i'm gonna be going
so um
yeah and now i hope people know
like
the third doses are basically available
to anyone who wants them just so people
know
um
but yes i am i am in uh situations where
both transmitting and at increased risk
for contracting due to
different
defense
present represented by council
so we're going to watch a little bit of
the ahmad arbury trial for contrast in
25 minutes the uh written house thing
continues officer asks if you could just
come forward
all right we've got the witness back
observation remind your under oath
all right let's go get the jury
so in my opinion this is a judge that
seems somewhat connected to reality i
haven't watched all of this to know for
sure whether the judge is not doing some
wacky stuff he may be
but compared to what we've seen in the
written house trial it's night and day
i also want to say thank you to paul
ossidik and ben rowe for signing up on
my website using the coupon code
uncharged pickles uncharged piccolos you
are new members 14 and 15 today
did you see the judge asian asian food
comment yeah we reviewed it earlier
judges material today how to butcher a
murder trial by chef medico
david thanks so much for the extra
content also the minnesota accent is
worse than the wisconsin accent
okay that's an opinion that's an opinion
this is a pretty scuffed courtroom i
have to say it looks more like like a
basement
conference room
i'm banning people almost faster than i
i almost can't keep up with how quickly
we have to be banning people it's wild
that's a cough that's a serious cough
by the way are there just no more masks
in courtrooms anywhere this is in
georgia right and then the
written house is in wisconsin there's
just no more masking
thanks to walter franco for signing up
on my website thank you walter pleasure
having you here
pleasure to have earned your support sir
and don't worry we're watching the
written house
it's starting soon
excuse me um we are ready to proceed
with the evidence in the case
mr ribbon
good morning officer
officer i want to go back through
your direct examination and some of the
things you've described for the jury
um
you talked about
uh initially kind of satila shores as a
neighborhood
would you agree with me that still
shores is a nice middle-class
uh scenic neighborhood on the little
stila river yes
and uh you describe the the folks who
live there is primarily elderly right
yes sir there are some people who have
kids yes they play outside yes sir uh
the adults walk the streets plan their
work in their yard and enjoy the river
yes sir
you've been patrolling that neighborhood
for how long
uh
seven eight years maybe okay
and
you've gotten to know quite a few of the
residents through your work
for instance canvassing the neighborhood
this guy this attorney sounds like
lindsey graham and looks like that
college basketball coach uh roy
somebody remind me you guys know who i'm
talking about right
some of the posts some of the times on
the page yes and this
facebook page is actually a pretty good
tool for you isn't it it can be yes
because people on facebook will post
about crime in the neighborhood yes
they'll post about roy williams about
crime in the neighborhood yes they'll
post about their suspicions about crimes
in the neighborhood yes
and how often would you say you review
the facebook page in setilla shores only
when i knew that there was something
going on
if i knew there was an incident
today then i would go today or tomorrow
and start looking to see what people
would post okay
so we're talking about today this time
period between
october 25th
2019 and february 23rd 2020
during that time period
approximate for the approximate for the
jury how many times you looked at the
facebook page to see if this black male
was seen the one scene at larry
english's house was seen by other
neighbors were talked about by neighbors
in the neighborhood
i don't believe i could put a number on
that more than five
more than five yes okay
and in reviewing the facebook page did
you learn about other crimes not
committed by or suspected by the black
male in the larry english house but by
other people
who were missing
lawn mowers and
suspecting other intruders and things
like that no i did not okay are you
saying there were no other posts or you
just don't recall them i don't recall
any other okay you wouldn't you're not
saying there weren't posed by people
like brandon gregory's father-in-law
you're not saying i'm just asking if
you're saying that
well
hearsay
and the facebook posts are there's
nobody here to testify to those facebook
posts and putting it out there that well
have you seen this and that
at this point the facebook posts are
here say as to what anyone said or did
well i think we just have a name of a
person that may have posted so
i'll refresh rephrase
see how the whole vibe in this trial is
much more sensible and adult than what
schroeder's running
crimes were suspected crimes in the
neighborhood
i don't recall any specific now you know
okay
instatella shores lives one of your your
peers sergeant brandon gregory yes you
know sergeant gregory i know sergeant
gregory sergeant gregory's father-in-law
i do not know his father-in-law okay
in canvassing the neighborhood did you
ever speak to sergeant gregory uh
sergeant gregory yes i have okay
and he gave you some information about
his
suspicions about the black male who was
entering larry english's house right yes
he did okay
in fact we didn't see it i don't think
on the video
of february 11th but he shows up on
scene february 11th doesn't he he does
yes and he provides you with information
about
a black male that he suspects is
committing crimes in the neighborhood
yes okay did you follow up on that in
any way i did and turned out
the elderly couple at the house where he
saw them was an elderly black male and
female that lived there and neither one
of them
i spoke to the male the female was in
the residence but she was out of sight
they claimed they did not have any kids
any grandkids and they did not he did
not the male who answered the door did
not recognize
the mail on the picture recognized
and that picture to be clear was a still
of the october 25th video yes it was and
that's the one that you used throughout
yes sir okay well let's go back then to
let's go back to then what you knew
about crime in the neighborhood during
this time period
you were aware that travis mcmichael was
a victim of a theft correct yes you were
aware that um
ronnie olson was a victim of a fact
ronnie olson man who lived across the
street we see him saying i can light
this i know who ronnie olson is but i
don't recall
i don't recall any crime at his place
okay were you aware that diego perez was
a victim of that i was not aware of
diego crazy okay so the only one you're
aware of then is it just in that little
part of the neighborhood is travis
mcmichael and larry english that and i
would say the herndon residence it's
that general area of the neighborhood
down and that's down jones road uh on
jones road itself
do the harness live on no not on jones
they live on satilla drive the same as
corner of setilla and zellwood the same
as where mr english's property is
further up towards highway 17 yes sir
what is the entrance okay
so let's go back then to to the
beginning which is
um october 25th
2019. yes sure there's a call
from larry english to
glenn county police and you get
dispatched yes and you get dispatched
with
other police officers as well correct
yes um an officer and i may pronounce it
wrong
bergadius
and then officer dixon officer dixon yes
okay and if you don't recall i can show
you these two refresher members
you go out there
the property that you're you're going to
this is your first time on the property
first time yes it's 10 o'clock at night
yes
it's dark
yes you go onto this uh this
construction site but it's a house yes
under construction
and
tell the jury what you did when you
arrived on scene
i without going back to my camera i
arrived on scene and walked through
check the property for the individual
that was called upon okay and you knew
from the video
and just
you this is the clip and i'm looking at
states exhibits
121 yes
you do from looking at this clip
you can answer that question
you knew from looking at this clip
that um that lit well this is the clip
layer english sent you yes
and
what you knew about the incident he's
complaining about is there's a black
male
on his dock
at 10 o'clock at night yes a guy who has
no authority to be there yes and no
legitimate reason that you know of to be
there exactly and so
described by mr english is plundering
around his his hey jaby i just made you
a moderator on youtube appreciate the
help
you reviewed the video did you review it
when you got on scene or before you got
unseen
afterwards afterwards i had him send it
to me afterwards okay when you get on
scene the house is dark
now you described the black male as a
light-skinned black male
but you understand that
the color of the skin
depends on the camera that's taking the
picture oh my god i'm not
all into the technology of infrared
based on what i see there that looks
like a light skinned black male oh my
god
what his natural skin looks like in
daylight hours i have no knowledge of
that
until video at a later time on february
23rd february 23rd and you've looked at
that video you're gonna have to look at
the pixels guys
so
the mail's there
i mean in your video clip but you get
out there on scene without the clip and
you go to the dock
yes you have your flashlight yes you
have your revolver uh yes is it out uh i
don't believe it's out at that time
because no one's described anybody being
armed at that point no sir okay go
through the house oh yes we do
flashlight yes sir because without that
flashlight it is pitch black in the
house yes okay
look around you don't see anything
of note
right
you don't see any body of note closer
okay
and you leave
when you file your police report right
yes
but you then you get the video clip
right yes
and i get it before i leave the property
that night okay so you had it before you
leave so just in case as you're driving
around the neighborhood you see someone
who fits that description yes okay
you understood also on october 25th
that when he left larry english's house
this unidentified for everybody just
joining us
the written house trial resumes in 15
minutes we're just checking out the
ahmad arbory trial a little bit
we have an issue we need to take up
outside the presence of the tree
ladies and gentlemen if you go ahead and
retire the jury room
it's all right
wow
chat's getting a little bit out of hand
again we may have to go member only
again it's getting pretty ugly just like
why are these people flocking to my
stream these people are vile i want to
say thanks to rhonda flack cynthia kelsh
and fiona haynes
uh the women are extremely over
represented as new members during the
streams which is fantastic to see we
love
um
um
i don't necessarily know that he needs
to step down for this okay all right
um
your honor
miss sue b lawrence
was not at home on october 25th
and she then tells diego perez something
and then diego prez tells this officer
something
i asked mr rubin are you going to go
into this because it's here say within
hearsay within hearsay because diego
prez is telling him something that sue b
lawrence said
and he said no i'm not going to go into
that and then it's you knew that soon he
went towards sue lawrence's house so the
only way this officer would know that is
if diego press had told him that that's
a good attorney told diego press so now
we're going to triple hearsay here and
i mean
so i didn't ask for any hearsay in that
question and the way he and this is what
i was asking the way he knows he went
towards lawrence's house is because
larry english made a second 9-1-1 call
that's in evidence on october 25th
saying he's going across the street to
the whitish yellow house and he went
there it's not hearsay it's exactly what
he did
ask the question so the question i
thought was and and he ran to sue
in the direction
of sue b lawrence's house correct and
that's in the 9-1-1 call
he doesn't mention subie lawrence by
name but he describes the house and in
fact officer rash went there where did
you learn that information i
i could not recall if it was actually
from dispatch or while i was on this
judge seems normal diego perez was out
walking around that night
and until i did not know exactly did it
come from
this bad fortune or from diego crazy one
of the other let's just clarify that we
can move on from there then and i won't
i'm not asking what diego said or
anything like that okay um
that's another one it could be one or
the other and that was my concern it's
like we're going down this path where
we're going to trickle you're saying i
just want to cut it off before we're
done
yeah i'm not going to address anything
then before the panel i understand what
the witness is testified to and there's
the possibility of two different reasons
or two different reasons for him having
that knowledge
you're welcome to follow up on directly
all right let's go
the jury's coming back in we are still
covering the written house trial which
will resume in 10 minutes and today
they're gonna basically go over the jury
instructions
on what is self-defense etc that the
jury will be given so it's a very
important day then deliberations will
start monday after the closing
statements but we're just keeping an eye
a little bit on the ahmad arbury trial
for the time being
to drew stevens by the way who just
signed up on my website drew i really
appreciate you doing that
your new member number 20.
mr maybe you could just clear the whole
thing up by asking him that question
where he learned that okay how he knows
let's not worry about it let's move on
to whatever your next question is
whatever he did yeah becomes rough okay
judge seems to be in control
please
welcome back
all right
we've resolved the matters we need to
resolve we're ready to get back into the
evidence mr ruby thank you officer rash
after checking out larry english's house
did you end up going over to sue
lawrence's house i did and what did you
do at supervisors i tell the jury i went
over and knocked on the door i noticed
that she had a
blink
a black square camera on her front porch
shining down towards the walkway leading
up to the door did you look around the
house or just go to the front door i
looked around the rear of the property
is fenced in
so i looked around the front yard and
would be the left side which faces jones
or jones road okay
um
didn't see the black male no
by that point did you already have this
video clip
do you know would have to look at the
time that was actually sent to my phone
versus the time that i
was over there
when you went to sue b lawrence's house
were you aware that larry english had
called back
to the clinton county police department
describing where
this man in his perception was going to
uh yes okay
and so that so then you went to sue
lawrence's house yes okay
while you were out at sue b lawrence's
house did you see a man named diego
perez uh yes i did and without telling
us anything diego perez said
what was he doing out there
uh checking her property
do you know if he was armed i do not
okay did you ask him no i did not did he
get in your way in any way no he did not
okay so he was looking around the
property at about the same time you were
looking around the property
um was he still in his box of shorts
i did not recall him being a boxer
swords okay fully dressed uh
i'm assuming yes dressed
yes as far as you're not as far as the
nose dressed okay
um
if i understand correctly
you
received the next call
to go out to larry english's house on
november 18th is that correct
i believe so yes sir okay um and that
would have been your second time out
there
okay
did you um at the time you went out
there on the on november 18th have
larry english send you the video clips
again yes okay so when you went out
there on the 18th
you knew you're looking for the same
black male who's come back on this
property yes
and this time if you can play november
18th
and this is state's exhibit
uh guys people wondering what's going on
the written house trial resumes in seven
minutes we're just watching the trial
over the killing of ahmad arbury our mod
arbory is not on trial
for just a few minutes
song video clip the boat on the left
hand side of the of the video right
that's not the boat where larry
english's electronics were stolen from
no sir that's a smaller
um just both for tooling around the
river yes sir not as offshore but yes
sir but you understood by the 18th and
correct me if i'm wrong that he had had
a incredible restraint by the judge here
not yelling at anyone yet or
interrupting to talk about food i do not
know the date and time that he called me
and told me
that okay so it's
and this time you're still with other
officers
yes
dark yes you go into the scene
you have your flashlight yes sir you
have your gun uh yes sir is it john
uh while we're checking i
don't recall okay
because at this point
you still have no information that this
man is possibly armed no sir okay
no reason to worry about a threat at
that point no sir okay
but it's now struck you that
twice the same black male has entered
larry english's house yes and
didn't catch him
he's gone you know by the time you get
there he's gone now twice yes sir how
long does it take you and believe me i'm
not criticizing you at all you get the
call you go how long does it take you to
get there on these occasions you know
that could vary very well i mean
am i on another call
do i have to finish up there it could be
if i'm just out riding the from the
central location of my area five to
four to eight minutes okay so within
four to eight minutes
at best four minutes worse eight minutes
the guy is gone yes okay
on the 18th when you check out the
property and i assumed you checked out
the dock area yes
there's a camper on the property just
like we saw on the 11th you checked out
the camper area
he's got valuables stored at this
property right
uh yes it's got construction valuables
yes saws and other tools right yes
elements boats that are valuable yes
equipment within the boats that are
valuable yes he's got a camper that
contains his belongings yes it's his
property right yes sir even though it's
an open construction site it's his
property yes sir and he has a right to
keep people on or off as he sees fit he
does okay
you're now there twice you miss him
twice yes do you know how he gets away
on the 18th
uh
other than walking away that's it okay
do you do any other steps that night
take any other steps to find the
blackmail just canvas the neighborhood
okay when you say canvas and this is on
the 18th are you just patrolling the
neighborhood or are you actually
knocking on doors
driving around shining the spotlights
okay doing doing what you can to find
this elusive blackmail yes okay
you get a call from larry english on
the 1st of december
but you're off duty yes but he describes
for you a suspect
someone he thinks may be involved in the
theft of the stuff from his vote
yes so is it fair to say to the jury
that by december 1st
you know
larry english has been
burglarized objection
to that characterization so that's not
all what their english said or testified
to
well i'm asking this officer's
perceptions at that time
relevancy as to this officer's
perceptions at that time of what larry
either said larry english testified
yesterday whoa whoa
let's go to speaking objections
larry english has testified his
testimony is in the record you're asking
this witness
what his recollection is and what it's
based upon as i understand it okay okay
with that so
okay
by december 1st
2019 you understood that larry english
was missing his yeti cooler
right i knew he was missing a cooler i
didn't know it was a yeti but yesterday
we just gave a plug to yeti
an epirb satellite system yes
and another piece of electronic i think
a microphone system yes okay
and
you understood
that the items were taken from the
offshore boat that had been parked at
larry english's house yes right in the
same area where this boat is now parked
in states exhibit 120
123. yes at rv garage yes sir okay
of course you're off duty last thing you
need is to uh get these calls all right
i'm going to step away from this because
we are now uh at this going to be at the
start of the written house trial i did
just get one comedic element sent to me
from the david pakman show subreddit
that i think is pretty funny that i want
to show you guys
what the written house defense and judge
were worried about if pinch to zoom were
allowed this is good
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
could it change the course of the entire
trial
[Music]
yeah so that's what they were worried
about and um that's why that's why pinch
and zoom was such a controversial
controversial thing
um okay we are now standing by for the
start of the kyle rittenhouse trial day
nine
um i do wanna thank people who have been
supporting the streams and signing up on
my website those people for now are joe
arena
michael wilfel i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly
chris brown great to have chris brown
here
chris baldwin
and someone who wishes to be known only
as sir your wife is up in the air that's
six people signing up putting us at 26.
if you're just joining us we have a new
coupon code exclusive to today only the
code as you can see above my head is
uncharged pickles uncharged piccolos
and um that is live it's a massive
discount
uh and also
if and when we get to 50 the mustache
will be locked in over the weekend and
i've promised that i will darken it by
monday's show
okay all right good i think we're on the
same page
as far as that goes
um
okay some people say stay on stay on the
arbory
case
um until this starts all right let's go
we'll go back to it a little bit to your
frustration no one knows this guy
no sir no one can tell you where he
lives
no one can told you no one even
told you they saw him jogging in the
neighborhood
right a single person
has seen him jogging that you talked to
now i did not specifically ask have you
seen this guy jogging but
no one had seen him in the neighborhood
period
tell us
about
how many people
over the course of those months that you
talked to about this how many people did
you talk to
a dozen uh
12 to
10 to 20 people okay
you're showing people the stills not
from the november 18th but the stills
from
uh october 25th video or both
uh
i believe
from the 25th still from the 25th guy on
the dock yes okay
and um
you're letting them know
that this is the guy seen up at 220
satilla drive yes
some people might know larry english but
i assume most did not know who he was i
have no idea on that okay
when you did you did you asked people to
review their surveillance
uh videos to see if he might have been
captured on certain dates on those
videos
i never encountered anybody that had
video
that
so yeah no i didn't ask anybody to
review okay
they seem to be running very late in the
written house trial the next time you go
out there is february 11.
and february 11th is now your your third
time responding to larry english's house
i believe yes you're aware though that
um
that
other officers have been to larry ing's
house right yes are you talking to these
other officers i have
interacted uh
a couple times
just passing on
like um at the end of our shift the end
of the beginning of next shift let them
know hey be on the lookout you know pass
along to the next officer
i believe i called
i believe it was seth officer powers on
the phone and passed on some information
because our briefings is we don't always
see each other face to face i would just
call hey are you working baker nine
tonight or are you working baker nine
today be on the lookout
and officer powers is one of those
officers who did respond to larry
inkster's house on the 17th of november
i believe so he does right when the the
white couple came to his house you
didn't respond people in the chat i hate
to break it to you
but
if you're gonna come here and say
david you're an idiot c-span is better
because no one's commenting
just go watch c-span what's
what's the point of coming here at all
just go to the stream you enjoy
michael's calm yes
were you aware when you got there
or on your way there that the man
who is now seen on the 11th of february
is possibly armed
uh at one point travis says that he was
appeared to reach for his pocket or his
waistband
i do not recall if that was related to
me via dispatch while i was in route or
once i arrived on scene okay
so we saw a video and this time you're
not just going in with your flashlight
this time you got guns drawn
so does that help refresh your memory if
it does
of
when you heard that the man in the house
is possibly armed
yeah that would i would say yes
and and what does your memory
now tell you is when you about when you
learned this
we went in with our guns drawn
based on that
the dispatch told us that he was
possibly armed that's a gun drone
while we searched the residence so this
is a different situation
you're now going to house and you might
encounter a man who has a gun yes
heart pumping yes adrenaline flowing yes
okay now you got to be on your really on
your toes yes
and we saw another
officer with you um i think his name is
trenton but trenton sherman officer
sherman he's there with you yes
at some point
did you hear officer trenton say
and i'm just using the
quote i missed quote tell me
where are you at [ __ ]
i don't recall hearing that okay
at this point though
um
you're not tight okay
here we go
so uh the written house case is is
getting going
critical
critical
critical day in the written house trial
because this will be
the defense and the prosecution
arguing for the instructions they want
given to the jury
about the basis on which they are to
decide guilt or innocence
a mass this is an entire
area of the trial in and of itself that
is incredibly important okay the jury
has heard testimony
and seen evidence
but they need to know how the law
applies to it
and so this is going to be um absolutely
critical and then closing statements
will be monday and then the deliberation
is going to start on monday
i want to thank people who continue
supporting the work that we are doing
here logan carlson just signed up on my
website joinpackman.com
joseph glenn is a new member daniel
cameron just signed up jennifer
nippenberg is a new member
kyle magdzak
i think is the pronunciation domi watley
and susan olivas have all signed up on
my website same appearances
except except uh okay hold on
the jury's not here and we're here to
talk about instructions and verdicts
did you get on mike's sir and uh the
district attorney has
requested a uh
by the way how are the calzones
multitude of lesser included offenses
um
are any or all of them opposed
i'm looking at i'm sorry i'm looking at
their
sorry
so
i have count one just the first degree
i'm sorry the the uh
first degree reckless homicide i didn't
see
any lesser included on that do you oh
yeah they asked for 10 20 did you get
the written request for instructions i
did
they asked for 10 22.
oh they yeah that was an email last
night did you get that i did
okay they asked for 10 22 which is uh
is not the standard for first degree
reckless homicide it's uh
it's the standard for
first degree with uh lesser including a
second
okay
okay
um
okay are you objecting to its giving
yes
i
don't want to discuss it briefly or just
impose or
argue
object for the record
i guess i would just check for the
recognition
all right then um
i'm not going to decide right now
because i just got
your filing this morning which was sent
to the clerk and kenosha they sent them
to me directly
and i know you're not familiar with that
procedure so let's take a break lunch is
here
and actually i wish less people had my
email right now but um
but
i think that's probably a common feeling
[Music]
uh
um but um
um
i will i'm what i plan to do is to sun
at some point tomorrow
i will send you what i expect
to
deliver as the
final instructions and verdicts and
i would sus now
uh
given the evidence i uh
well i'll leave it pizza is here um
and then we probably will have what i
hope will be a brief discussion on
monday about it and
at least you'll have
the food is here
whatever you do make sure you go to the
bathroom somewhere other than the
courtroom
that was the craziest moment
don't use the courthouse as a bathroom
he told them
what a judge
i guess i guess i will talk about it for
a minute the difference between first
and second degree and you're asking that
i said mid second degree
and it's it's in the instruction itself
on the bottom of uh
i don't want to say bottom because i
don't have them displayed as they would
on the
page but on instruction
the instruction you've requested
which is 19 excuse me 20 10 22
uh
under the heading
difference between first and second
degree reckless homicide
it says the difference between first and
second degree reckless homicide is that
the first degree offense
requires proof of one additional element
that the circumstances of the
defendant's conduct showed utter
disregard for human life
um
then of course the standard for
submitting the lesser
is what is that there's ground in the
evidence to acquit on the greater and
still convict on the lesser
where what where's the absence of
evidence of utter disregard for human
life there is a line of questioning on
the cross examination
of the defendant in which
uh
trinity binger asked i believe in
regards to each
person shot or shot at
except for that of mr mcginnis i suppose
if the defendant
uh
i can't remember the exact wording but
if he even cared if he killed
the person
the person alluded to so i believe that
the defendant denied that he said he had
to shoot him he
he denied that he did not care about
their life so i believe the jury
could find based on that line of
questioning as well as just the evidence
in general
that the
defendant did not have an utter
disregard for human life
as he testified
he testified that he essentially
had regard for human life because he
felt he had to do it
and he didn't really want to kill anyone
well the circumstance well let's hear
from the defense
dude element three is the circumstances
of the conduct showed the utter
disregard for human life
um
and
in terms of the evidence in the case
um i think the testimony was he didn't
want to have to do it
but he did it
to defend himself so
as i said in our instructions i i don't
think that there has been any
uh evidence offered which would support
um the lesser included on count one
so i would ask the court give 10 20
which is the first degree reckless
homicide charge along with the
self-defense instruction and that'd be
that because i think that's what the
evidence shows
i'm going to do a colloquy with your
client um
when we get done with all this and don't
let me forget please i've discussed it
with him yeah but i got to talk to
person
uh well
the instructions says in determining
whether the circumstances of the conduct
and that's a correct point
the conduct showed utter disregard for
human life consider these factors what
the defendant was doing
he was firing a gun into
let's see this is count one so we're
talking about
mr
mr rosenbaum he's firing a firearm four
times into a human being
with
fatal consequences
why he was engaged in that conduct
how dangerous the conic was well that's
self-evident
how obvious was the danger that
self-evident
whether the conduct showed any regard
for life
and all facts and circumstances i don't
i don't see it
and
i don't see it help me out where i'm
going wrong well judge he was asked if
he
not only did he
how he felt about killing them
but
if he knew that his conduct
would have killed him and that firing
that gun
would have killed his element is
on first degree which is what we're not
talking about
is
whether he knew or was practically
certain
uh and we're talking about reckless and
danger or reckless
homicide so
i mean to fire a gun four times into
somebody you don't think you'd know or
have
or be practically certain that that
could have fatal consequences
i would but the defendant denied that it
did that it would
um
he didn't i didn't hear him deny it he
said he was protecting his own life
i thought he was
when he was being asked repeatedly and
correct me if i'm wrong
he was asked repeatedly
along the line that you indicate and
they responded
i was trying
to defend my life
he was also asked the line of
questioning
you knew if you shot four shots that you
would kill him and he denied that he
would have that knowledge
so i i and i
agree that
i mean i obviously think that it's
under his regard because that's what we
charged it as
um and that's what we have presented to
the jury but i believe a reasonable jury
and a reasonable juror
could based on the defendant's own
testimony
not fine
utter disregard for human life and
that's the standard not what we think
but what a juror could do i wish i knew
the exact answers that were given
i'm not sure and i i i when i say that
that doesn't mean i'm
embracing your
your interpretation of what that would
mean
but it um
i would want to be sure exactly what was
said anyway
so um
are you able to identify whether in the
examination because you had a very
lengthy examination
and check my notes
and you know unless it's crystal clear
my suspicion would be if if it turned
out that the defendant would be
acquitted when not acquitted but
if the jury returned a verdict on
second degree reckless endangerment with
this description of what constitutes the
crime
if they've returned a guilty verdict
over the defendant's objection i would
expect to be reversed
on secondary reckless endangerment yes
all right
homicide i'm sorry
so
you're saying if the
jury finds the lesser
on this charge and the defendant
objected over the defendant's objection
and you accepted it right you felt it'd
be reversed yes
unless you can come up with this crystal
clear language that
the defendant
and i again we're back to
the circumstances of the defendant's
conduct
showed utter disregard for human life so
i i think
his thoughts on the subject would be
relevant would be a would be a
legitimate factor but it seems crazy
when i consider the others what he was
doing
firing into somebody four times
why he was engaged in it there was
dispute about that
but
either it was um
any circumstances and uh
except
under privileged circumstances
how dangerous it was how obvious was the
danger
and whether the conduct showed any dis
any regard for human life
i would love for a lawyer to clarify but
my impression is that the judge is
making it difficult
to include the ability for the jury to
say not guilty here but yes on a lesser
charge that's part of this charge
overall about his intent what was the
question you're seeing again
there's a line of questioning on if you
if he
cared about killing someone or or cared
in that in that regard there's a lot of
questioning is you knew that firing the
gun
would
could cause death i believe he denied
her indicate he didn't know i don't
remember that did you did
everything that he said i mean the
reality is
everything wasn't
was an intentional act now they haven't
charged it that way and i appreciate
that but looking at the looking at the
definition
of utter disregard under the statute i'm
not going to repeat i'm going to hold
the same ground that you've already done
how dare bingo wear a tan suit
evidence that the man grabbed the barrel
of the gun so we're talking about a
distance of inches not always feet but
in some situations inches
it is
the only logical conclusion would be
that a person would believe that that
conduct if they were convicted
uh would show and under disregard for
human life if self-defense isn't
accepted there's no other reasonable
conclusion that can be drawn from firing
a gun
somewhere between one and four feet
all the way down to inches by the soot
on his hand so i think that's what the
evidence showed uh and i think that's
really the only evidence uh regarding
the utter disregard portion of the
statute so
if the defense is going to stipulate to
the third element and that's fine we can
go for it that way but it seems they're
not arguing it if we want to go that way
then we can
conversations with lawyers are always
interesting
oh my god
uncharged pickles
and if they're if they're not going to
stimulate then obviously there must be
some
uh disagreement or they might they must
be trying to argue it so i believe that
there is a basis i cannot recall
at this moment precisely where in the
cross
cross-domination
occurred
obviously it was likely and
i was not conducting it the examination
as i recommend as i
recollected
um
that the defendant was
repeatedly asked
about
the question about his
thoughts on the subject of the
death or survival of uh of the
target
invariably responded
that he was trying to defend himself
and that he'd be killed if he didn't and
if anything i i would take it interpret
it as an indifference towards
the outcome
with respect to the uh
um target wow why why is the judge even
weighing in on to
utter disregard
right but right so if he shows if he's
indicating he has an indifference that
would be secondary reckless
no it would be one factor and i i i
don't even if i granted
i i just don't think it's appropriate
and as i repeat my statement wow
if i were to give this instruction over
the objection of the defense
and the jury found a verdict on it
i would expect to be reversed
well are we in agreement that
that element three is present well don't
ask me i'm not uh
i'm not in a position to agree to
anything
i'm not going to do that
um
on uh or or submit that verdict
1345 and 1347.
is the is the judge negotiating a plea
agreement
by the way how are the calzones so it's
essentially the same issue
yeah it is
any additional argument on that
interview the same for a count three as
well
well
counselor is a good point to me that
he claims he didn't even know mr
mcguinness was there so he's firing
a weapon
who's he admits does not know the
capabilities of he admits he doesn't
know
how the bullets can react that he did
not know if the metal jacket could pass
through his target um and he's really
showing undisregard for anyone
in the line of fire as he fires four
shots including mr mcguinness there's
also bystanders there's a house uh
directly behind mr mcginnis uh so i
believe in in firing four shots and
a somewhat i would say wild manner um he
is sure
that there could be an argument that he
he says he says
i believe again
that is under disregard
but
a jury could find
because he did not know mr mcginnis was
there that he was not showing under
disregard for mr mcginnis's life
and that the second degree uh endangered
would be more appropriate obviously
obviously
just give me one second here judge um
thanks to christopher webb and dunning
krueger for signing up on my website
joinpackman.com appreciate that very
much
numbers 34 35
and tell me if i'm wrong on this because
it stems from
the actions involving mr rosenbaum
which this court
believes the proper instruction deals
with
the utter disregard for human life of mr
rosenbaum
those actions to me are intertwined
with
the charge involving mr mcginnis no i
don't think so because um
i think the instruction
he anticipates that he could
he could have utter disregard free
could have utter disregard for the life
of mr
rosenbaum
but still be sufficiently aware
to realize the risk
to mr
mcginnis
and then he under the law as i read it
he would have the obligation
to exercise
his conduct is in such a way as to
minimize the risk to mr
mcginnis whether privileged or not
he would even if even let's let's talk
about his kind of being purposeful even
though it's not charged
uh if he intended to kill
mr
um
rosenbaum
and
whether he was justified in that or not
he's still required to to to execute his
intentions
in a way
with the minimal
or to minimize the risk to mr mcginnis
so if
and that's a jury determination i i'm
not suggesting i would want to be in
that position who would but
he would have to decide well i've got to
kill this guy but i've got to do it such
a way that i don't hit anybody else
that's really the what the jury's being
[Music]
asked to determine
and uh
there are instances
that you could imagine where
the person actually would have freedom
of choice and
the judge is like introducing new
considerations and hypo hypotheticals
self-defense circumstances guys just so
you know the jury's not here the jury's
not here i see people saying how how is
the jury jury is not in even in today
although for an intentional intentional
then he'd be guilty
because he intended to kill someone else
and here's my only argument is
i think the testimony was the bullet
that
has endangered mcginnis
passed
through
roosevelt
right can you imagine if rosenbaum was
shot
there's five
wounds with four shots so
he didn't miss
so the reason that i'm kind of hung up
on
the utter disregard for rosenbaum is if
he would have missed i suppose
and you could say that shot was a wild
shot but he was using steel jacket and
ammunition
bullets are bullets george
no i don't know i'm picking in hairs
because that's what we lawyers get paid
to do but um
uh you know and and of course you know
if we were in the jury room and we'd
laugh at each other for the things that
are being said
uh but but
uh
you know in the eyes of the jury
hell is wrong with this guy
theoretically like how many angels fit
on the head of a pin
they could theoretically think well it
does make a difference because he wasn't
using
um expanding ammunition he was using um
a
full metal jacket and he should have
foreseen that it might have gone through
and then it would endanger someone else
also imagine he was there so the jury
invariably he did he did indeed he had
that was my next point
um
well my only argument judge was that if
if he's using utter disregard or the
jury believes he there's utter disregard
as it relates to mr rosenbaum
the the
the charge as it relates to mr mcginnis
directly relates to the bullet that went
through mr rosenbaum's hand or head or
whatever right so that's why i'm saying
if it's that
if it's that for
rosenbaum it has to be the same for
mcginnis only because there's not a wild
shot he didn't
he didn't miss he wasn't spraying
nobody's alleged anything like that you
couldn't say that in your argument
couldn't you
if i left this on their verdict and uh
you had to argue and you could say
i certainly could jesus find me i said i
could
the evidence does show that he
essentially missed the third or fourth
shot there's a graze wound that then
travels who knows where possible mr
mcginnis so this is not as though
all four bullets entered
mr rosenbaum one
skipped right by oven
uh basically to contact me
and the defendant says he didn't think
he was there so a reasonable jury could
find that how do you show utter
disregard
for mr mcginnis when the defending
claims he didn't even know he was there
i'm going to think about this one i at
my inclination at this moment
uh to repeat my former statements that
have caused some concentration
my bias would be in favor of giving the
submitting that verdict and giving this
instruction but
if it shows up on your doorstep
your email doorstep
tomorrow at some point and it doesn't
it isn't in there don't be terribly
surprised
all right uh hell
the cop four
so are we so count three
it's the essentially the same issue
except obviously this time the defendant
knew he was there
um
arguments that i believe firing
two shots
uh
missing
a reasonable jury could find that he was
not sure how to disregard he only fired
twice instead of four times
um he did not
fire into
the
individual after already striking him
twice as he did with mr rosenbaum he did
not continue to fire
so i believe
the mere fact that he fired twice and
did not hit
a reasonable jury and again
we believe that first three is the most
appropriate charge but a reasonable jury
could find that because he stopped
firing he was not showing utter
disregard
we are talking now about a jumpsuit
a jumpsuit what are you calling blue
hoodie man what do you mean
um
did you want to respond
it's the first time i've ever heard that
missing
someone when you're firing from point
blank range
means that you're not showing an utter
disregard for human life
um so
he fires
at
i mean judge he's on top of him when he
when he when he kicks him in the face
and you you saw the shots
it is
difficult
to ascertain an argument that
a jury would believe because he stopped
shooting or missed
from point-blank range with an ar-15
that he wasn't showing utter disregard
for human life i i don't think that's a
logical argument i think the appropriate
instruction is 1345.
they're either going to accept that it
was self-defense in that or they're not
but to say point blank range
two shots on a man jumping on you the
defense i think is rightly picking up on
the fact that some of these including
some of these lesser charges
would not be good for ridden house
because self-defense aside
it could get him convicted on lesser
charges given the circumstances
the the standard
for the lesser included i think is still
there is ground in the evidence for
acquittal on the greater and conviction
on the lesser
the same set of facts
what's the difference
between what you're charging
and the lesser i've seen i mean the
difference is my worry is that
the defense who is i've asked now a
couple times if there's going to agree
there's no disregard and they've not
agreed they've not agreed to do that is
that they're going to get these
instructions and then
argue it in their closings and then we
are stuck so i would like some sort of
limitation
why wouldn't they argue in the closings
what the instructions are
that they will argue that there's not
under disregard
that they'll argue the opposite of what
they're saying now no i i'm not hearing
that
hasn't happened yet
why not agree to it
if they are agreeing that
maybe not that's why how would that be
they'd be nuts
why in the world would they concede an
element like that
oh my god right now
i know they're not they're just off
they're discussing it for purposes
of whether or not the lesser included
should be given
it's they're saying they're not
conceding all your evidence they're
saying it's hard to believe that this
would constitute or not constitute our
disregard for human life let me let me
repeat the question i just asked you
he seems to basically be saying if we
include that he's going to be found
guilty because he obviously did it the
disregard part
he the
the video is claimed to depict
that he kicked the accused in the head
that the accused turned and fired at him
twice and missed
on what ground could they convict him
of the lesser without having convicted
him of the creator
there's
i'll stand by the prior arguments of the
defendant's own statements and also
i think it does make a difference that
he shot four times at mr rosenbaum
after he had already was already
crumpling to the ground
um that he the fatal shot was as he was
falling to the ground
and he stopped shooting at the man in
the blue hoodie
uh
and
again
i think the first degree is the
appropriate charge but i think a
reasonable jury can say why did he stop
firing why didn't he uh
you know fire at him as he as he went
away i fear he might come back and run
at him
so i believe a reasonable jury could
find that and
uh frankly if if the defense uh in their
closing argument
uh
tries to quibble with the utter
disregard i'd
i've never expressed it before but i
think we're national western included
after that because
that we're going to ask for lester
included after that if
um
if they're admitting here that there's
no way a reasonable jury could find
otherwise
if they're agreeing to that that's one
thing but well if they are agreeing to
that
right i think graham who i believe is
the attorney from the other day is
saying juries love to split the baby if
you have an all if i have an all or
nothing defense i don't want to give the
jury options right so the prosecution
seems to rightly be realizing that if
they include these lesser charges
the probability for a conviction on some
of the later counts and lesser charges
on the main counts becomes much more
likely the defense seems to be realizing
the same thing which is why they're
arguing against it
firing a gun at a human being yes
he hasn't alleged that he wasn't firing
at him
he wasn't saying i was just trying to
scare him off with a couple of shots
across his bow he didn't say that
why he was engaged in it
and he's given his reasons
and
i i don't think the state disputes them
he was doing it to
to to to prevent
the
man
from attacking him and
the state says the man had the right to
attack him and the defense said he
didn't
either way
he was doing it for the what he was
doing it was purposeful
how dangerous was the conduct well
the defense is not disputing it wasn't
dangerous behavior
i don't think they're gonna argue that
oh man how obvious was the danger
the defendant denied that it was
obviously dangerous he said he
he did not
know if it was going to kill him he did
not uh know that he denied knowing or
that his bullets were more dangerous
than other types of bullets he denied
knowing that his gun was more powerful
than other guns
so
again
i hate the evidence mostly i don't think
i don't think that that is exactly it is
exactly what it was
stated for example discussion about what
kind of guns are more powerful that
wasn't actually i was
kind of intrigued about it because it
was a close contact and the suggestion
was being made by the questioner mr
banger that um the rifle is a because
because it's a more powerful weapon is
was more dangerous or something to that
effect and of course in a close contact
situation like that it may be that the
pistol is a much more desirable weapon
um
[Music]
but i thought that discussion was
focused on
that type of issue
rather than
your claim that the defendant was
suggesting his weapon wasn't dangerous
that it wasn't obvious danger wasn't
obvious
the judge isn't even pretending anymore
judge in his testimony the defendant
said essentially
i was injured for my life but i didn't
mean to kill him
is that what he said or did he when he
was asked did he mean to kill him
he said
i was just trying to defend my life or
what's that effect
he said i did not want to kill them
did he i don't
remember mr binger says yes mr kraus
says yes he said i think that's fair at
some point or another he did say he
didn't want to kill anybody that's true
that night but that's not the element
for that therefore first degree
then that'd be another matter this is
reckless and this is reckless
endangerment
we're talking about the defendant's mind
if it utter disregard
no we're talking about how obvious was
the danger
wow the judge is committed to not
allowing the lesser charges
or disregard what we're fighting about
is
that it's not
i'm still struggling with what is the
basis
upon which the jury could acquit of the
greater
and convict of the lesser because that's
the standard
if they believe the defendant they have
a basis for the lesser of them
there is a basis
up the defendant i didn't want to kill
anyone
but i didn't want to tell anyone that he
bought the gun because that would mean
that
i might even buy into that
i might
except that that would be
if we were talking about a charge of
count
or
four
because
intending to kill is not an element does
he ever interrupt the defense
but so that i have disregard if he's
firing and not considering you're
getting to the ultimate fact and i'm
telling you what the factors are and
determining whether there's our
disregard and you're telling me
that one of the factors to be considered
on whether it's utter disregard is utter
disregard
that doesn't make any sense
well like i said
i believe the defendant's testimony
gives a reasonable jury a basis to find
a second degree
i don't
so i will not give that instruction wow
or submit that verdict that's terrific
for the defense thanks to the judge
right i mean wow
and the reason is because i do not feel
there is basis
in the evidence
for acquittal on the greater
and conviction on the left when it's
good for the jury i'm sorry when it's
good for the defense let the jury decide
when it's not good for the defense he'll
he'll decide
i want to say thanks to damien kazakh
kazakovitz damian kazakovitz who made a
pledge via patreon patreon counts double
today that gets us to 37. also thanks to
andrew boyer
kathleen carolyn
and kyler
kyler gilbank for 1017 which is
for signing up on my website thanks guys
appreciate that three lessers
first you're asking for first degree
intentional
you're asking for second degree
intentional
or
okay for this super chat you don't need
my permission to quote things that are
public
you don't need to ask me for permission
on that
so now give me the basis
for acquittal on each of the greater
crimes and conviction of the lesser
well
the first contentional homicide
obviously there's a self-defense uh the
jury could find imperfect self-defense
and
find second-degree intentional homicide
that if he did not
uh reasonably believe the force
it was if it was not reason what sorry
it was not reasonable for the
amount of force used uh the defendant
again while testifying said he did not
mean to kill mr huber uh so they could
find from that alone that there is not
an intent
at all and go to the first degree
reckless
and then we're left with the argument
that we've been having all morning thus
far
which is uh whether a secondary reckless
showing utter disregard would be
appropriate
the defendant said he didn't mean to
kill him
the defendant it gave his reasons why he
thought he had to shoot him
but
again
i believe he indicated he
denied that he knew it would kill him
and
essentially it's the same argument
that's been being made all morning but i
think it's quite clear that in a
self-defense case second degree
intentional is appropriate
because the jury could very easily find
in this case
that it was not perfect self-defense
as a person
who has is running at him
being told or perhaps even witnessing
himself that the defendant has already
shot someone uh ingrediently injured
them has already shot at another person
missing
and then gone in to try and disarm him
the jury could find that it was not
perfect self-defense
hey are you disputing that
no first and second first and second no
intentional or okay yeah okay so then
the reckless the defendant testified
directly that he did not intend to kill
him
and as good as uh first degree reckless
no
okay
all right any objection of the second
agreement for the exact same reasons
that we had talked about mr huber i'm
sorry judge if you already no no that's
all right mr hubert has a uh the
evidence was
a rifle pointed
up against his chest i didn't hear you
he has a rifle according to the evidence
he has a rifle pointed literally
up against his chest
so the idea under those circumstances
that having an ar-15 pointed
uh buttressing up against your chest
would not be utter disregard for human
life if believed uh to me that's where
it begins and ends there is no other
explanation
so i think first degree
second degree lesser included first
degree reckless are all appropriate
second degree reckless doesn't fit
uh did you understand
i understand our arguments before
this afternoon we may review the
defendant's testimony and
if i find a specific thing that i think
changes it i will obviously contact the
parties okay
i i
embrace the argument of
uh mystery sora shroff see
and count five
you are and that is the
shooting of mr gross kreutz
and that is charged as
uh intent to kill
correct okay
so the insertion i requested
is attempted first and then attempted
second uh for very much the same reasons
as mr huber that a reasonable jury could
find
imperfect self-defense
as mr grosskroitz
was actually facing away from the
defendant when he fired
and then the
the next lesser included
if they don't find intent
is the first degree reckless
endangerment uh so i've requested that
and then obviously i requested second
reckless endangerment uh which we've
rehashed a few times now
defense judge i don't have an objection
to
uh the lesser included on the second
degree attempt
um
it's the same argument the court heard
the evidence in the distance mr girl
scouts testified that he was
about three feet away whatever it was
from him
um when he was shot uh
the gun
mr gross coach pointed the gun at
the defendant
mr rittenhouse then fired so i think
that first degree attempted first degree
well you can't attempt a reckless act
right and i would have told you i would
agree with you uh some years ago but um
i i i'm i'm not sure about i don't i've
attempted reckless acts myself now i'm
gonna have to hit the books on that with
the calzone
by the way that was certainly once the
law i would have you either are to me
you're either reckless or you're not
reckless so i would
object to any recklessness because i
don't think you can attempt
a reckless act so
i'll leave it at that and let the court
ponder that
well the defendant did testify that he
didn't want to kill anyone
i understand that but i think you i
think somebody would say you're the
behavior is either it's either reckless
or it's not
i don't know how you can attempt to be
reckless or attempt to be negligent i
don't know how you can do those things
good job
i mean we just basically agreed on uh mr
huber that uh reckless homicide was
appropriate
mr grosskreitz did not die so the
appropriate charge in this point would
be the first three recklessly
endangering safety the jury could easily
find that
the defendant intentionally shot
mr grosskroitz which is not
i guess a dispute but that he did not
mean to kill him the defense the
defendant said multiple times i did not
want to kill anyone the jury could also
find
that
shooting someone in the arm if they find
that was where the defendant was aiming
would not be intent to kill but it would
be recklessly endangering his safety
uh if the jury does not obviously find
that it was perfect self-esteem is it a
lesser included
yes
statutorily yes
yeah i think you're right
because otherwise why couldn't they
convict him of both
um
but why get into a discussion we don't
need to resolve how reckless was his mom
in bringing him to this insane fiasco
i don't know i'm going to think about
this one i i'm inclined to agree with mr
krauss
the food is here okay um
good point justin yeah david attempts
reckless acts all the time with his
coupon code on count six we are not
requesting any to endangering safety
charges so we can skip that argument
bless your soul um
now the defense has submitted and i i
don't think you submitted anything
standard except the standard on that uh
we our position is they've never raised
the affirmative defense
so that's why we need to do it at the
trial
right
let's see
and
obviously argue otherwise that's why we
did not prepare for them
obviously they can argue otherwise but
that's why we did not prepare one
quick thanks to daniel colavecchio and
john newman for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com appreciate that puts us
at 42. we're getting close to the
mustache surviving to monday which means
it will get darkened in evidence
correct me if i'm wrong
as to the third element of the second
defensive matter which you cite on the
second page on the third page
item number three on the third page
i don't i don't recall that evidence
i i would agree there was no evidence
thank you how can i give that
instruction oh because they have the
burden of proof
it's not a strict liability offense yes
17 years old
yeah if there's an absence in the
evidence that's kind of a problem for
you know
what what do you mean you would need to
disprove the affirmative defense we
don't believe it was ever raised they
never gave any evidence as to
uh barrel lengths or that oh yes there
was there was definitely barrel length
evidence
on cross examination of the state's
weakness whenever it happened it was
there
well now i'm now i'm i know i'm not sure
there was evidence of the
of the uh man this guy is just the worst
measure the length of the portal that i
asked
detective
did you yeah
assuming that to be true
then that would
and that was less than actually it was
the barrel length was greater than 16
inches
wait a minute
either the barrel length was less than
16th or the overall length was less than
26.
that was in the evidence what i asked
him was there was there any uh
did he believe i want to make sure i
have it right so i don't misstate it
did he believe that the barrel length
was
in violation
of the
law you can't have it you're talking
about it okay yeah okay and that's built
into it okay
certainly come on it's not a strange
issue in this case i mean we've been
talking about it for months
well and i agree with god for months and
the defense should have measured the
barrel in front of the jury and said the
burden of the burden of proof
that they didn't if they raised it they
never raised this issue well did he he
did he asked
hey graham can you comment on that in
any affirmative defense does the burden
of proof not ship shift to the defense
is that is that not the way it is
in other words if they're like yes he
did do the killing but it was
self-defense is isn't it not incumbent
on the defense to prove that it was
self-defense there was
a violation of the law as it related to
the barrel length
that goes to his belief
and they never specify which law
they have to raise the issue
i understand i don't believe that they
have
there and there's no testimony on the
authorization uh
distributive accomplishment to paint
authorization for hunting
there's no evidence on whether or not he
has a certificate of accomplishment to
obtain authorization for hunting uh
which is the state's position all along
is that he would have to have that
well they're claiming it's in the
alternative
and the state is always saying that it
is not
so we're backing well if the court finds
they raised it which i don't believe
asking
a general question on the belief of a
uh detective uh that is not evidence the
belief of someone
um
well i is it a belief or an observation
the way attorney
just said it was what was belief i we
we'd ask you the exact question but i
don't believe
the exact question may become important
so i i don't believe that is raising it
and the defense said every opportunity
they
brought the gun over here
most every day the last few days um they
could go to any number of witnesses to
measure it and raise this issue and they
did not they don't have to measure it
that's the burden of proof of this on
the state i understand that but it
wasn't raised
well if if he asked the officer and i i
will have to see what the transcript
says if he asked the detective
whether the barrel whether the
rifle was compliant or
what are you claiming you said
i asked him if if there was i believe i
i know i asked him about it the
questions the question i asked i think i
asked him something along the lines of
did you believe there was any violation
for the barrel length of the gun
oh that's that would put it in issue if
the question is like that well also the
statute reads
this section applies only to a person
under 18 years of age who possesses or
is armed with a rifle or a shotgun
if the person is in violation of section
941.28
or
is not in compliance
with the two sections mentioned so
it's
it's an or it's not an and we don't have
to show all three
so they may have raised the issue with
so one of the three
you have to show one of the three
no no no what am i saying
no we have to show you have to show any
of the three
which the defense has put in issue
really confused he has not put an issue
the certificate of accomplishment
correct the defendant has put an issue
the length of the barrel
judge
we can unpack this for a minute so this
the exception says
if you're it's a violation of the law
okay let's see we've got some commentary
here um first ahmad al-haltham says
haitham says only as to the defense
itself no other part shifts in the
burden of proof
then graham says who's a defense
attorney two kinds of burden of proof
production and persuasion self-defense
has a burden of production meaning the
defense has to bring enough evidence to
justify the instruction okay
also this is crazy xavier says xavier
says just attended court in a suburb of
wisconsin before court began the judge
gave an unhinged speech about how fox
news covers real news and how he
basically thinks kyle rittenhouse is
innocent that's an appropriate speech
for a judge to be giving in a different
court because it's
it's he has to be in violation of both
29 304
and
29
593. i concede
he's in violation of 29.593
however
29 304
he's 17.
it doesn't apply to him
it can't apply to him because of his age
we put in his age and we put in the
barrel
those are that covers the first
exception
and then it goes to or and it covers the
second exception
as well
i i provided the court and i'm not
rehashing it that you had denied the
motion for reconsideration
this statute doesn't apply to 16 and 17
year olds period
the legislative history that i provided
to the court it says it in black and
white well i ruled as i did because
the motion to dismiss attacks the
complaint
and the complaint was adequately pled
under the law that was not an
endorsement of the state's position on
the case
and where the
to use the trade expression the rubber
hits the road to here at the trial
so now you have to prove everything that
the statute requires
and i i you do you dispute the fact that
you need to prove
that the defendant was under 7 18
at the time of the incident you know
that's that's not a dispute that he's
under 18 yes and
that the barrel length was less than
that allowed by law
or was then it was not within the range
permitted by the law we don't have to
prove that you don't have to prove it
i mean there's no real
our argument is that they did not raise
it i don't think it's really a disputed
fact
but we believe they did not properly
raise this first part of the exception
the second part of the the second part
of the exception they've conceded 29
points
go ahead i'm sorry they've conceded the
29.593 portion he did not have a
hunting certificate
so then we go to 29-304
and if if it is allowed then simply
being 17
he is in compliance with that it
swallows the whole statute and it makes
this actually makes no sense so if this
makes no sense you're out of luck
interruption is valid it's clear as day
that it says
a person
i would not say that about this law
well i would maybe not say that about
the exception but the actual law
can you imagine
sure any person under 18 years of age
who possesses or goes on
oh my god
our position is that he is not in
compliance with 29.304 and 29.593
and i know that this was
scoffed at when i mentioned it before
but
16 year old seven 16 and seven year olds
can hunt alone in this state
if they have the correct
certificate okay
under 16 cannot and that is what 29.304
is addressing the statute is addressing
hunting
you know this basic law is that the
rubric is not part of the statute
the blooper
the tank
the turtle is just you're just walking
by person under 18.
it's not part of the statue
what's he saying it is i learned it in
the earlier time when we called it the
rubric
that's what the statute says though
that's what it says in two ways
the hell um
the state's position is that he is not
in compliance with those two
um and that they have not raised the
surprise shotgun issue
this short barrel shotgun issue but they
don't really have to because they can
try to raise
the other part but they have not done
that either
it's raised on the second part it's
raised that's true so that's it and
i just want to make sure i've been
losing this argument and
it's not judge there are hunting
portions of that statute
and there are just simple possession
portions of that statute of 29
304 i am not focusing and i'm asking
that you it doesn't apply the hunting
part
what this if you read the legislative
bureau what it says is if you're 16 or
17
there is an exception for you to possess
a firearm does say that semicolon done
it has nothing to do with hunting
nothing
i um
my inclination now
once again i'll tell you what i'm
inclined to do
is to inform the jury
um
let's see
thanks to daniel simmons for the patreon
pledge that counts double today puts us
at 44.
yes
legislative history only becomes an
issue when there is ambiguity there is
no ambiguity in 2a it is very clear that
18 year olds are not to possess
dangerous weapons
so you interpret the statute in a way
that makes sense and the way that it
makes sense is that simply because
he's 17
does not automatically
negate 2a
well you know i raised it earlier in the
case
and it hasn't enjoyed a lot of
discussion and maybe i'm off the wall i
don't think so
the penal laws are construed strictly
vague laws
are who's that who is that emperor from
way back in history oh no
oh no most of the laws
and pillars so high that the people
couldn't read them
and that's been used by
uh
by lawyers and judges for
centuries obama about the requirement
that people will be given knowledge of
what the law provides
and the basic law and and it's chipped
away a lot of times with the
appellate court decisions that are made
on the subject of
of um
and try and have efforts to preserve how
is this happening statutes because
some of them are
quite messy
and
that's not a criticism that's a reality
that judges have to deal with
periodically most of the statutes are
easily enough worked with but the basic
rule is that the ordinary people should
be able to understand what their laws
are
so they know what conduct is allowed and
what isn't
uncharted i've been wrestling with this
and now i know that there's a lot
brighter judges in this world than me
but i've been wrestling with this
statute for
i'd hate to count the hours that i've
put into it i'm still trying to figure
out what it says what is prohibited
now i have the good fortune of having
some experience and a legal education
how is the ordinary citizen supposed to
acquaint herself with what this law says
there's a testimony that
the defendant
mr black mr black's stepfather the
defendant's mother all knew he could not
legally possess this gun that's
that's why he was kept up here
that's why mr black bought it
um this
is very clear interpreting
i'm sorry is that the standard by which
the judges interpret a penal statute you
just said it should be clear to normal
everyday people and it was clear to
these normal everyday people
because it's very clear that under 18
cannot possess a dangerous weapon
and he
can't necessarily possess the gun
in illinois we're talking about
wisconsin and we're talking about the
law
not
what dominic black's father might think
obviously
well but the point is you know
if they put us
if they put a sign out here don't don't
jaywalk over to the other side of the
street
and that's a bad example because we know
jaywalking is unlawful supposing they
put a sign out there that said
don't
don't use your cell phone while crossing
the street
now if they adopt us a law that says
that
and people are as i told the jury before
uh
ignorance of the criminal law is not an
excuse so people are charged to know
that unless it's written on the top of a
pillar so i people can't see
that people if they're given legal
notice that's why they publish them in
the newspaper
if people are given a legal notice of
what's unlawful
then they can
conform their conduct to the
requirements of the law
if they
if they don't know what the law is then
they're just herded
into obedience
of certain standards now i don't know if
that's the case with dominic black's
stepfather
or father or whatever it was or the
defendant's
father or whatever um
whether they studied the law they were
familiar with what it says or they do
they were just afraid to break the law
because they heard somewhere along the
line
uh that it was unlawful well i can't i'm
not allowed to do that
i'm not allowed to
say well they should have they should
have guessed right
i can tell you i've put many hours into
it so have you
and um
how are ordinary
people
not supposed to
know what they should be afraid might be
against the law how are ordinary people
supposed to know what's against law
because 2a is very clear
i wish it were to me
um i'm going to install my intention is
to
instruct
on what he's submitted
without page numbers i might add
um
looks like the third page that starts
statutory definition of crime
and uh
down two
where it says or
so it'll be exception
the state must prove etc then number one
the defendant was under 18 number two
and that the dangerous weapon
was either a rifle etc
um
and you can search the evidence to find
out if you can prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that that's true
so that it can go to the jury
um
all right now um is that it
pizza is here
the state requested
the
805 810 and 815.
as well as 99
805 uh no okay 8 10 and 8 15 are the
retreat and provocation instructions so
yes
okay go ahead
well i guess i would ask this first
judge as it relates to 8 15 which is the
provocation instruction um
is the is the state saying that the
presence of mr rittenhouse there
is in and of itself
provocation uh no we are saying that in
the incident mr rosenbaum uh he provoked
it by raising his rifle and pointing it
at
uh individuals um
so that is why mr roosevelt then
gave chase to him
uh the defendant
the defendant that had a duty to retreat
he retreated
instead of giving notice of his
uh withdrawal from the fight he turned
and pointed his gun again
at mr rosenbaum an unarmed civilian
which he admitted he knew he was unarmed
uh and uh and that continued so no the
provocation is not his mere presence
um it's not his mere presence with a gun
we will argue that uh the video evidence
contrary to the defendant's testimony uh
shows that he raised his
uh weapon at
uh in individuals and that is what
provoked the attack
so judge yesterday uh obviously you
know why we were fighting about what
that enlarged photo
and
i don't think that's
what the i think that evidence is uh
open to interpretation certainly
um i would argue to the court that that
while
mr um krause can say that's what they
believe it shows
uh i would submit to you that what the
testimony is is mr rittenhouse is uh
shortly before that yelling friendly
friendly friendly
uh
i think if you look at that picture that
you saw yesterday it's open to
interpretation we know he's wearing a
strap
from the um the harness over his
shoulder
um
the other thing that if you look at the
picture closely he's standing
like he would be firing or pointing that
gun like he's left-handed
so if you look at the picture his left
foot is back his right foot is forward
and he's open like you're looking at me
now
so in every other instance where you
observed a gun being fired he's firing
it from the right side
with his strap as this gun hangs this
way
now they're saying that that photo
they're saying you just can't believe
the video and picking the gun up and
doing it left-handed
i think that photo's open to
interpretation as to what it is
we believe that it shows a side mirror
of the duramax
uh
and part of his strap from his firearm
or from his sling
oh my god i completely understand that
um
however
you also heard testimony that from this
person um who
from the state crime lab who said he
couldn't really answer and i don't know
what you thought of his testimony
yesterday but he really couldn't answer
a lot of questions on and that's why
color was so important yesterday on how
the pixels work and
he couldn't say how what color those are
and i think that's relevant
now it is our position and i think the
testimony supports the idea that mr
rosenbaum provoked the attack
mr rosenbaum provoked the attack mr
rosenbaum there's testimony from two
people that mr rosenbaum threatened to
kill mr rittenhouse if he caught him
alone
you heard the testimony that mr
rosenbaum yelled gun gun gun then you
know what was said after that
he's chasing him down
he yells there's been testimony that mr
rosenbaum yells fu
before this happens
mr rosenbaum
has a gun pointed at him in the parking
lot
and doesn't stop running toward mr
rittenhouse
and
if you give 8 15 which is the
provocation instruction
i would submit to you the only way that
mr rittenhouse then can be acquitted or
found not guilty of the charge
is
one he exhausts every other reasonable
means of escape
two he withdraws from the fight and
fight is the language and the
instruction
and three
he provides three
we'll go ahead finish and then i'm gonna
tell you why i don't agree with what
you're saying
okay
well i'm looking at 8 15 but i'll
interrupt you now and tell you okay you
said if i give that instruction
then the only way
no
the jury may not
believe the predicate facts upon which
the instruction is based
so he could be acquitted as long as the
jury does not believe
that the defendant's behavior
was provocative
that's the first line of the instruction
say that again that's the first line of
the instruction
you should also consider whether the
defender broke the attack the defense is
still able to give forward their version
of events we have multiple videos in
addition to this photograph um in
addition and also a defense exhibit
number 41 which has its circle on there
where the defendant is raising the gun
at someone uh in front of that duramax
that's an exhibit they have gotten into
evidence so there really wasn't much to
speak of this until a few days ago um
and um and that's fine they they can
dispute this fact
we believe it's very clear on video that
the picture itself is just one little
portion but on that drone video both the
full version uh and the somewhat zoomed
in version that has been provided it's
very clear i saw it on my television at
home immediately upon
watching it so that's our argument is
that he provoked it by doing that now as
the court has pointed out this is not
forcing the jury that there's probably
it's not uh forcing their hand they
don't have to find provocation it's you
should also consider whether the
defendant provoked the attack um and
that is a consideration and that is a
point of contention in this case uh and
i believe it's an appropriate
instruction for both
uh both incidents
i interrupted you no that's okay the
last thing that i was going to say is it
would also require that he give mr
rosenbaum
uh adequate notice that he is
withdrawing from
uh
the
the fight or the attack uh i think under
those circumstances that's
impossible to do but more importantly
i have found a case it's from kenosha
on provocation
and
what that means in terms of a
self-defense
that is state versus and i'll just spell
it it's b-o-u-g-h-n-e-i-t
[Applause]
g-h-n-e-i-t
it's at 97 with second
687
and
in that case there was a gentleman in a
in a diner
and people walked into the diner and he
started to harass them he started to he
tried to grab the women
harassing the women
verbally accosting people
and one of the men that the women were
with came over and said you need to
apologize the defendant said
let's go outside
so
they go outside the defendant ends up
going to his car
picking up a shotgun and shooting the
man in the face
and the
the um argument was did he provoke this
now there was testimony to everything
that i just told you
did he provoke that by by starting the
fight
sexually harassing the women
using the language he used and then
asked the guy to come outside and the
court said he did
so the provocation instruction is
clearly appropriate
i'm not
i don't believe there's sufficient
evidence
in this record
to support the idea that mr rittenhouse
provoked this attack
i don't i i don't think that that's
there
so
i understand that it doesn't require
that they follow that and say well he
did provoke it but i think there has to
be evidence to support that
um
and i don't think that photograph in and
of itself which is
obviously open to interpretation
supports the idea that that they have to
or should consider whether or not that
was provocation at that point
i agree the photograph alone
would not give the basis for provocation
the photograph is the last piece of
evidence that was submitted on this
detective entering he testified to it
uh we have pointed it out on videos we
pointed out uh to the defendant on the
video and he uh gave what i believe to
be a
lame explanation for it
um
[Music]
lame so
and again the defense's own exhibit
hasn't circled on there is it happening
so i believe there's plenty of evidence
that mr rittenhouse did raise this rifle
and pointed at someone off in the
distance actually mr zaminski
and let's not forget also i'm not giving
my full argument on provocation yet
the fbi video well let me go back
the cory elijah and the
drew hernandez actually frank hernandez
videos
i'll be back shortly folks the defendant
walking
behind rosenbaum mr rosenbaum on the way
to this car source area
at some point mr rosenbaum begins
running
we see that on the fbi
playing footage
our argument is that
mr rittenhouse then begins running and
following mr rosenbaum that he fought he
follows if not the whole way from the
ultimate gas station then mr rosenbaum
starts running that provokes the
defendant who is actually very slowly
and casually walking
for quite some time seemingly
to then go and follow mr roosevelt there
he then re and the defense's argument is
that this is some sort of ambush
i don't know how you ambush someone that
you don't know they're there but we'll
put that aside right i don't know how
you ambush someone you don't know is
coming but we're gonna put that aside
so the defendant runs onto the scene
and then is seen by testimony and video
evidence
gently putting the fire extinguisher
down he says he dropped it but he places
it on the ground and he raises the gun
and i disagree about the left-handed uh
thing that attorney trophy just said and
raises it
at
mr ziminski
that is all in evidence it's in a
defense exhibit
can i see that is that really available
the state's position is that
the running after mr rosenbaum probably
in itself is enough to provoke the
attack but putting that aside certainly
raising
a gun
and with no basis for any kind of
self-defense there's no one around him
at the time except an individual in a
wheelchair who's behind him
he raises his gun
i would guess because he thinks there's
vandalism going on
but we don't know that because the
defendant denied that he did it
and then mr rosenbaum
approaches he
somewhat drops the weapon he keeps two
hands on it and then he begins he has a
duty to retreat at that point under
provocation
and then he runs i understand why this
instruction is problematic for the
defense and for their version of events
but that does not change the fact that
pointing a gun which is in the evidence
is provocation
uh the defenses
wait a minute
which exhibit are you talking about
talking about the compilation video that
the defense bring to evidence i believe
it's 41. i have it on my screen right
now my computer yarn
then you said
uh well then you said we'll see if you
can match it up with what she's looking
at um then you said
that
the
something about
the running
one person running after another was
provocation how is that provocation
we're talking now about the
uh you're alleging that the defendant
was running behind
mr rosenbaum and that was provocative
that he chased in there
your honor
he's walking especially the video that
was put in yesterday through mr
hernandez he's walking within steps
rosenbaum and zaminsky are lighting the
garbage can on fire he sees my client
walking down the street with a fire
extinguisher and there's fires down at
car source mr rosenbaum knows where he's
going he's already threatened to kill
him he sees him coming he's got very
distinct purple gloves he goes down he
lies in weight there's no chasing going
on whatsoever i i where's the chasing
and how hey what era is where is the
chasing and how is that provocation
the propagation is the raising of the
gun
oh so because a moment ago you said
that the chasing was provocation
which of course it could be
i believe it is if it's all the evidence
sorry
i believe it adds the provocation
that he chased him there and then
immediately raised the gun
he wants the instruction and he's going
to argue what he just said five minutes
ago
well hey we're free to argue that
just like we're free not to stipulate to
the third element
uh what am i what am i looking at
there's a circle
i don't believe it's playing yet
so
show me with the pointer what what
you're talking about
i'm just pointing out that
indicates he's pointing a weapon
i'm just pointing out that this defense
exhibit indicates he's pointing a weapon
we have much clearer video showing this
and it still has
[Applause]
we'll take a minute
well i'm just
rereading again
i'm struggling with a couple of things
number one i
uh and then of course i haven't seen all
the
photographs you're relying on but
um
you would have the burden to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt the the
accuracy of what you're saying you have
to disprove the defense but
um
the defense's position
is that rosenbaum was yelling gun gun
gun
[Applause]
why do you think he was yelling gun gun
gun
[Music]
yeah the court is exactly right we would
have to prove this we have testimony
uh video and photographic evidence of
this occurring
it is our burden to prove it i agree
but the jury should be given the
instruction that they should consider it
because if he raised this gun
it's clear provocation
so
it's up to us to present the proof which
obviously will be a central piece of our
closing argument um with the
i think three different videos
um
this defense exhibit which at least
indicates that it's there
uh and the testimony of detective
antoinian who
indicated he saw this i believe after
cross-examination or on
cross-examination um
and the jury
the jury can decide it we don't have to
prove it beyond the reasonable doubt to
the court or to the defense right now we
have to belie uh prove it through the
unreasonable doubt to the jury on monday
there is plenty of evidence in the
record
to indicate that
to give this instruction i understand
it's problematic for the defense i
understand it's problematic uh for their
entire theory of the case that they
presented in their opening but that
doesn't mean that we shouldn't get it
because we have presented evidence of
this provocation that the unlawful
conduct uh provoked mr rosenbaum to
attack him if the jury
buys our argument
uh beyond reasonable doubt
fine if they don't
that's that's their prerogative they're
the fact finders not the people in this
room we have presented facts for them to
consider they should be given the
opportunity to consider those facts
in this light
judge i don't think that that photograph
maybe i'm wrong
shows anything
well that's for the jury though i
understand but they're asking out of
that photograph to give a provocation
instruction no no
we're saying there's no other reference
we're
[Music]
we've talked about the chase thing right
but every other thing that's come up
about what detective antoramian said
what anybody else has said it comes from
that photograph that's it no it comes
from the drone the drone video and
then the defense attorney the defense
knows this which is why they've fought
so hard to keep this out this is not
some new revelation it's in the police
reports their allegations that he
pointed this gun
this is only to demonstrate that a
defense exhibit indicates it we're not
using this to prove it we're using to
show that
that even the defense exhibit indicates
that this is there we have testimony we
have
video evidence we have i believe
photographic evidence that
helps but to say that we're basically on
a blurry photograph is completely
dishonest they've seen this video and
they know what's on it and they know it
is problematic for their defense yeah
you know i can't rely on what you think
they think
i understand i'll i'll change my
argument but the simple argument is
there's plenty of evidence that the
state has provided that he raised his
gun
it was a
known
[Music]
part of the discovery in this case
we
can we should argue be able to argue
that and we would argue provocation so
the jury should be should consider it
and they
clearly as they pointed out in their
evidence and their opening and argument
today they can
rebut that and indicate we have not
proven it and that's up to the jury that
is not up to us so i believe we should
give the instructions appropriate it's
add the following when supported by the
evidence and it is supported by the
evidence
you know um
there's been no secret about my
lack of lack of technical awareness
uh
in the trial here
and and just and i thought of it i i
decided not to intervene yesterday i did
ask
mr
well
armstrong armstrong
some questions
i tried to better understand what was
coming off but
um i didn't go further into it and in
spite of a temptation to do so
um when i get
messages from some of my friends my few
remaining friends i i have they come as
texts
and then they start
belittling me or whatever in one way or
another and and it can be quite lengthy
at the exchange that's going on but
between them and us and
and
but i they're entertaining
and so i make a
i don't know how to save text messages
i haven't figured that out and i haven't
you know i have a lot of things that i'm
doing
so that's a low priority for me to
figure out how to save a text message
and i don't want to leave them on my
phone forever
i want to off
so that it's clean so when i look at it
i'm looking just at the fresh stuff so
then i i do a screenshot of it and i
email it to myself
to save it
but i found it to my distress
some are pretty long and they show up
in my email
like this like a little ribbon
down the center of the page some are
even smaller than this
well
then i go to open them up
and it's just
a blur
you were talking the other day one of
you two
it's just like a cell phone where you
can expand a picture and make it bigger
well it's not making it any bigger it's
making it bigger but it's nothing but a
blur
that was my concern that i wanted to ask
mr armstrong about i guess i should have
for him to explain it better for me as
to how that can be reliable
because it isn't reliable for me and
getting my messages on my phone
now maybe if i reset it to a
to a site i could explode it again and
or or decrease its size again and
i don't know but
uh but here you've got a picture which i
have to tell you i think it's very
blurry
i agree and the picture is one of five
or six pieces of evidence so i know the
defense wants to focus on this picture
um
but
the picture is only one we have three
videos or well one unedited completely
untouched drone video which i think is
where you see the clearest
and then we have uh one that is zoomed
in and we have one that is slowed down i
believe the clearest shot is actually
the original drone video
so we can present that evidence and they
can rebut it um i i think i think you're
taking the picture wrong on your phone
i'm not tech supporter i mean i think
you're taking the picture wrong and your
phone just
i think so
right
but um
you know
these things are in evidence
you watched it on the screen yesterday
whether you formed your opinion or not
and that was not
what counts except to the extent that
if there's no
if there's no um
if it it totally got uh proud to be an
american
uh
unclear just totally unclear then i
certainly can't give a provocation
instruction
based upon a picture that
i can't make anything out of i agree
with you the ultimate determination of
what it shows is for the jury
you guys know at the end of the trial
the following will happen right not
based on the picture it is based on the
drone video
and the testimony and this was testimony
elicited uh if at least if not by the
defense then in response to their
questioning
uh detective entering and justified he
reviewed it and saw and that was a
common uh question in many people in
this case the main
the the photo is like the fifth or sixth
most important piece of evidence the
most important piece of evidence on this
point is the drone video itself
and that is unedited there are some
edited copies as well that are helpful
but
to focus on this photograph
that was almost an afterthought simply
because we didn't get it until the day
before and we figured it may be helpful
at some point
it is the photograph is we may not even
show that to the jury
um
it is based on the drone video and the
testimony of detectivement arabian it is
in the record
it is we have evidence of provocation i
i can't fathom why if there is evidence
of in their provocation which we have
clearly done
why we cannot argue it and why we can't
get that instruction the defense how
many more options have been taken away
from the jury while i was
that is gone i haven't seen it clearly
okay i have oh
your honor
they're arguing for something saying
we've been on notice from the beginning
and if they wanted to put on the
evidence to prove up provocation all
they had to do was call mr zaminski or
mrs zaminski to rebut the story that we
have they didn't put them on because
detective anteranian detective howard
both know he's a liar and they're
building their whole prosecution on that
without putting them on well they don't
have to call a particular witness but
they don't have the provocation and you
know we had all these little things
going on yesterday and i went back to my
office and
the whole essence
of the problem came down to these two
facts in the testimony
i went back to my office and they were
looking into sinks and showers hours to
manipulate that photograph to get that
blurry mess up on the screen
we had our expert do it right in front
of the jury and wait there's no way
that's true right
the judge said he saves texts by taking
a picture and emailing the pictures and
then they're blurry there's no possible
way that that happened right
again we're focusing on the picture that
is
again we're focusing happening
completely now is the least uh
the least well show me this one
how can i find that
yesterday before mr armstrong was
allowed to test find rebuttal
we went over this
about whether or not
the methods he was using
were appropriate and we showed you you
walked up to the 4k
and we showed you exactly what it is
we're talking and i'm not even going to
tell you what i thought when i saw it
remember what they were looking at
we have i know it and that's why i let
it go to the jury
it was crazy that's what we're asking is
that the jury be allowed to consider
the state's evidence is essentially what
we're asking i i don't think your honor
you would have allowed mr armstrong to
testify yesterday i don't think you
would have allowed him to testify
rebuttal
unless you had made some determination
that there was some basis for this what
i made a determination was that
i thought the jury should make
the decision and that's all we're asking
um
so that's your best picture the one i
saw people are looking for that meme
format that i just put up it's in a it's
in a post i made on the subreddit and
it's on our discord okay you're asking
me to give an instruction i want to see
the best picture
uh oh my god
we need to get mr stuart over here i
think he has real i'll poop in the
sandbox if i'm not allowed to play in
its sort of vibes
by the way how are the calzones
oh man thanks to amanda hudnall and
paige foshee for signing up on my
website joinpackman.com putting us at
46.
we are so close
to locking in the darkened mustache for
monday also i saw someone in the chat
say if we get to a hundred they will
have david pakman show sinks and showers
tattooed on them
that's something interesting that we
should probably look into
oh also thanks to magnum satan for the
patreon pledge those count double today
which puts us at 48. let's just do
another free item from my store whoever
comes in at number 50 you can get pick
any item you want from our online gear
store
and we'll ship it to you
are you talking about 82 bring it up if
you would uh which is that
um
what a day what a day huh i think using
the defense we we've got
the exhibits on our uh one of our
laptops that i think mr stu has i've
texted him to come on over but i think
ms wisco is uh
graciously uh
going to be able to play them for you i
would recommend watching them on the 4k
tv i think that's the best
way to see them
so we can set that up there is a the
full drone footage there is the
slow down drone footage and then of
course we have the uh photographs that
mr armstrong had yesterday
so this is crazy
let's take a break lunch is here
but uh we have subway tomorrow
pizza is here
the food is here
oh man
nicholas hobner is new member number 49.
very very close here
if it's not 4k
what's that is it this tv
adds pixels to something unless it's 4k
quality it does next to neighborhoods
it's common sense and judgment jim
did you hear that
i'm saying there's no evidence
i'm asking what are you saying
well it's common sense
where is kyle going
you brought it on tv
so that's what we're doing
what the hell is going on
was it is it a 4k drone camera on a 4k
tv is that what's going on
all right brooklyn george
is new member number 50 brooklyn you get
a free item from my store email info
davidpakman.com and we'll tell you what
info we need
i want to say thanks to david who made a
pledge on patreon as well
this is the this is the unedited okay is
this unedited
yeah this is the internet
so judge we're
gonna be focusing your attention right
here at the base of this uh sign okay
that's where the defendant is going to
come into
now
can you imagine guys
i almost need a windows sound sound
board version is much clearer yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
so what you're showing me now is this
doesn't show anything
yes
okay
massive technical issues
sitting right down there this has got to
be a performance doesn't it isn't this
just a performance by the judge
i want to say thanks to some really
great people joshua hatton scott speer
elder brown
tristan lucero
hunter lambertson bryce arnold nick
schwarin one two three four five six
seven
thanks very much seven people signing up
on my website putting us at 59
also thanks to richard bosley who made a
patreon pledge and those count double
pushing us to 61.
judge that's flowers and pears uh could
be bartlett
could be boss
is it pronounced boss pear or bosch
get vaccinated
there you go
oh man
no signal you love to see it
you really do
i really want to say thanks to magnum
satan for upping their pledge from two
dollars a month to a hundred dollars a
month via patreon that is absolutely
huge i appreciate that
i've not cut the audio guys the court
has cut the audio
um
looks like maybe some stones sticking
out of water now that the judge is
looking at
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
oh man
this is a field
of lilies
looks like some kind of tea set
big thank you to ollie wright ollie
wright just signed up on my website with
the coupon code up in the air sir your
wife is up in the air
but of course today's coupon code is
uncharged pickles uncharged piccolos
right
judge in your estimation is this more
okay no they took it off
any resemblance to starry night with
this image judge any at all
the judge may throw out three more
charges on the basis that it's not
really been demonstrated that pluto is a
planet
it's legit crazy that this is what's
going on i agree with you guys it's just
wild
is this the zoomed in or the regular
this is the regular
so we're looking right here this is the
defendant
he puts down he raises it up right there
he hasn't played it until roosevelt
approaches and he runs around
wouldn't you think the defense lawyers
would tell kylo rittenhouse to just stay
sitting down at the defense table
can you slow it down
we have a slow
right here's the gun
right there's the gun right here
right like the jury can decide whether
they buy that that's kyle rittenhouse or
not the jury can decide that mr
roosevelt
here stew let me
pause it one second in please
pause
right here if you watch it when he goes
right up here he puts the fire signature
down gently
it topples over
and he immediately raises up
i mean honestly is it can a lawyer tell
me is it appropriate for the defendant
to be leaning over with his head like
two feet from the back of the judge's
head the way he's doing right is that is
that appropriate i've never seen that
look at him look at how close he is to
the judge i've just not seen it gun gun
gun
we would argue it's to war all these
people that he is pointing a gun at that
and he is chasing him out of the out of
the area it's not normal
but if you see right here the state
believes
with all the motions taken
that's the gun and here's the
it's right here
uh you know we can talk about this on
closings do you want i was just curious
what's that
so why'd you play from the beginning one
more time this is crazy
it sort of seems like the judge's
position is if the judge isn't totally
sure that it's written house he doesn't
even want the jury to be able to
consider this i mean it's crazy
or lower it i should say
would you like the zoomed in or slow
down one i'd like to see if the enables
normal speed or slow speed do that
enhance the zoom in normal speed
sorry guys i just have to ban about 10
more people i apologize
thanks to max roy for the patreon pledge
those count double today
also thanks to rachel burke slightly
cropped and
normal speed
oh
so
this is the defendant right here you can
see the ar-15 is on his chest
the fire extinguisher you can't see
right now it's blocked by this man in
the wheelchair but you'll see him walk
up again he will slow he will gently
place the fire stickers on the ground
although it'll fall over and then he
will immediately raise his gun up and
point it at the individuals who are over
here who i think are right now blocked
by this street life
but they're the zavinski's
okay go right
you see him lifted right there
he's holding it right there until mr
rosamond approaches
you see that
very distinct motion of him raising his
arms you see the black
gun being raised one more time please
you'd agree he's fake if that's true
he's left he's doing it
open to the camera
that's not for them to even debate right
now
that's crazy
thanks to bray hildebrand for signing up
at joinpacman.com thanks bray
so here's the gun or bree i'm not sure
here
he still has it up right there and then
he drops it and runs
would you like to slow down version
um
yeah
slow down version please
zoomed and slowed please
next element please
i genuinely have never seen the
defendant just kind of hang out by the
judge looking at exhibits like this i've
never seen it we've covered a lot of
trials it's just it strikes me as so odd
so here's the defendant here there's the
ar-15 right there
player please
so he's coming to frame he drops the
fire extinguisher and he raises it right
up
he has it up right there you see him
bring it down
and you see him start to run
he's pointing it
at joshua zaminski who
probably is vandalizing or queening
arson but that's another thing
uh we don't believe he has his gun out
at that point
what i meant to say
was because it depict
mr zuminski
mr zaminski's
uh i don't believe it shows mr
zaminski's gun i does it show mr smith
can you play it again brian he's kind of
good
they're kind of hidden by this light
post
okay that's all right is it okay
[Applause]
what i'm looking
it's wild because there are other cases
where where if there's a defendant that
killed two people with a gun
circumstances aside
they wouldn't be allowed to stand behind
the judge with there's no there's no
court officers around i mean okay i'm
not saying handcuff him the entire trial
that's considered prejudicial in many
cases for the jury to see the defendant
handcuffed but this is very strange we
did not try to do any enhancements on
that yeah
i mean we know from the fbi video
we we know from the fbi video your honor
that they're in this proximity alongside
the duramax but because they're darker
clothed and the duramax is a dark
vehicle and of course other issues with
the video it's not and there's poles and
things so
they're in that vicinity and the fbi
video which we can show you
so if you play it i think i can
play it please brian
they're blocked by the light post but
they are right here i think this is one
of them here
moving thanks to nash
for signing up on my website thanks nash
number 67 today
but then they they walk down this way
this is where he
we we don't accept the defendant's story
that he had his gun out because in the
video you clearly see
mr zaminski pull it out of his pocket
fire in the air then put her right back
in his pocket so unless he had the gun
out and then put in his pocket in these
few feet uh we're not accepting the
defendant's story in fact we believe
this contradicts his story that mr
zaminski had his gun already out because
uh you see um
on the next enhanced video you see him
pull it out of his pocket
and fire in the air quick and then put
it down he's walking he keeps it down on
the side he's walking right down the
sidewalk killing that dude just shot
somebody you can see the gun cleaning
um
did you want to make any um
observations about this before i make a
decision
you're going to see
okay so that question is does that video
provide enough information
to give an instruction on
who they say
they don't know each other
they
there's no evidence of that they can
call themselves mr roosevelt is dead in
his defense of others well and his
shooting is pointing a loaded firearm
which is a miscommunicator without any
real basis well
the evidence
the evidence
from two people is that mr
mr
rosenbaum
had twice before threatened to kill the
accused
so
is it
what is the legal what is the legal
effect
of a person who if
he made such a threat
what just legal
justification does he have
to chase after the accused
we are not accepting the evidence that
that threat was made because there are
different accounts of where and when it
was made
and it's like the only five seconds not
caught on video all night
so
but
like you said judge it'll be a great
argument and i i do not believe
that simply
mr rosenbaum
does not give up the
ability
to be provoked
because he may have said things
an hour earlier
um
if if this individual now remember there
is evidence in the record
uh that he was accused of pointing guns
at other individuals for property crimes
uh the defendant admitted he responded
sarcastically to one of them
on the video he sort of sheepishly and
quickly walks away
after admitting he pointed a gun at
someone for property crimes
the state's
belief is that he pointed a gun at mr
zaminski for another property crime and
this dangerous behavior pointing this
loaded
powerful weapon at someone for
at the most perhaps stoking a fire
that's already been lit
uh would be provocation
the committing this unlawful act would
be provocation for anyone
to intervene and try to chase him away
whether or not it's threats have been
made
and
i i know your honor takes these threats
seriously but we've also seen
thousand thousands of threats to kill
that have never been acted upon um this
guy mr osbom was described as a babbling
idiot there's no evidence he ever caused
any physical harm to anyone that night
um
frankly even if he had threatened he had
no means to carry out his threat
so
uh
as you said it's a great argument
there's evidence in the record
not just by video also by testimony
and
there's enough evidence to give this
instruction if the jury
does not
uh accept this argument if we do not
meet our burden uh
that probably is beneficial to the
defense but
uh it should at least be argued as the
evidence does support it and it goes
directly in contrast to what the
defendant testified to
pretty straightforward argument
do you want to respond
judge it's been
hashed over i know
well it's the jury's
it's the jury's case and i think they
should make the critical decision there
you go
um
i um
my
decision will be to submit the case to
the jury with the provocation
instruction there you go and you can
argue
the strength or lack of strength of the
respective evidence
so i will give that instruction and i'll
give the
you didn't dispute the retreat did you
i don't think it i i did i don't think
if you look at the comments it's not
necessary it says right in the comments
the committee concluded that while
reference to duty to retreat is arguably
unnecessary the defense is almost
against there being any charges big
surprise use of force
it's advisable to continue to publish it
it is intended to be optional in the
sense that it is to be used only when
the trial judge concludes that retreat
is an important issue in the case and
the jury's understanding will be aided
by a statement of rather than the
general legal standard that applies so i
don't think that under these
circumstances there's any
i can't say it's unfavored but if you
look at the comments there's no reason
in my opinion to give it he does retreat
there's no argument about that
but i don't think it's necessary to be
given
i believe that it is appropriate
in large part because this was the there
is no duty to retreat was mentioned
uh in opening i believe attorney trophy
referenced it in a cross-examination
that the defendant had no duty to
retreat so i believe that there should
be that's been put out to the jury there
should be a fuller explanation of what
that means that they can um
they can decide and they can see if
there was opportunity to retreat we see
the defendant
uh has plenty of open space in which to
retreat he does so right after shooting
mr rosenbaum um and also
uh well yeah now i'll say that
the whole everybody was scattering that
and that dramatically changes the
situation if you look at the fbi video
where he ran to there was absolutely no
one there before the shooting
the fbi video does not pick everybody up
the xanan video shows the clearest day
there's a hundred people over there
bashing on windows
i don't remember which it was i think it
was a name
video and
to me depicted a large number of people
who were engaging in violent activity
well
property violence but it's still they're
using uh clubs and
wrenches or whatever else to be
doing destruction to those cars that are
right
in the area
which would have been the
the path of flight for the accused and
i'm wrong about that yes
video you hear the five gunshots you
hear the first gun shot which is mr
zaminski and there's kind of a flinch of
the crowd and then you hear the four
shots that kyle fired yeah let's have a
look at it
i sure i sure formed the impression when
i looked at it
that this is
just to the south of the uh area where
the shooting took place
and uh that there was a very large group
of people in there
who would were intent on
ryda's activity
i i agree that in the southern portion
of the walk there is the defendant
testified that his first instinct was to
try and head north on sheridan that he
could not because mr rosenbaum was there
but as their testimony is that he was
somehow trapped or blocked in these
rather
loosely parked cars and you will see i
believe in the video that the route the
defendant takes
after shooting mr rosenbaum i don't want
to hear but after because after that's
such different situation entirely
watch watch the video let's watch the
video
sure you can put the sound on if it's
there
so we're here passing the hospital
so
so
if you pause it please
or go back two seconds
the defendant runs here there's no one
in that area
wait for the gunshots
which comes in a minute
i'm
thanks to kyle anderson and cinco obama
for signing up on my website new members
68 and 69 today
thank you
pleasure
a couple super chats
chat let's focus on one thing if he's
found not guilty his life is already
publicly ruined by the majority of
america no he'll actually be a hero to
many
he'll probably get speaking gigs and
stuff like that
the judge is setting up a dangerous
precedent if he's fighting for verbal
threats alone is enough to kill in
self-defense
david just started tuning in to the
trial what's up with the judge why do i
get kangaroo court vibes
kyle rittenhouse walks what are the odds
of a civil suit against them good
question
david regarding written house standing
behind the judge while watching video
rittenhouse is not in custody
it seems to me that there's quite a bit
of fight from that otherwise congested
area after the shots are fired
so the prior to the shots being fired
there were quite a crowd there what uh
judge i i don't believe there's a crowd
where the defendant ended up retreating
to
but
ended up ended up as after the shooting
had occurred
i understand so my main my main my main
reason for wanting this instruction or
our main reason is that the defense has
already stated that there is no duty to
retreat
that
so they've already put that in evidence
i imagine they will argue it again in
closings so i believe the jury should
properly be able to
uh instruct on the law and guarding
retreat
would you want to respond
you're on he's arguing the instructions
i'll give my
i said he's arguing the instructions
i'll keep that you saw the video judge
there
it's
there's hundreds of people with weapons
causing damage what happens after
doesn't matter
because it happens after and
i'm trying to do this on the law which
is that
it's it's unnecessary based on the fact
that self-defense is going to be given
and the question is
was the use of force in the situation
reasonable
that is contemplated
by not giving 810.
that's what the committee says
my inclination is to give it but if i
find it's adequately covered in the
other instructions then i won't
okay
okay
all right anything else
judge i don't know if there's any jury
instructions obviously
uh this case
anyone can pull up any video testimony
of anyone testifying
um i'm just wondering if the court
feels that appropriate or allowable to
play portions of testimony
to the jury on closings
you mean from media sources yes
wants to play court tv
well i'm not saying i'm saying we should
talk about it now before you try well
that's a good point
i i don't want to specify one uh you
know tv is certainly
and i might add has done a magnificent
job
in this trial
um in in staying out of my way and uh
and then just keeping things going i
think yeah so i'm not saying this you
shouldn't follow that i just
you could use uh any source that is
carrying it except
not one that where they're commenting on
it one way or another of course no one
would do that at least not if he knew
what was good for him um the um
so unless there's some objection i don't
have any problem with that i don't use
appropriate we're not seeking to do it
we i just wanted to
i just wanted it out there before
someone tried to do it i mean i'm happy
to agree that we're not going to do it
oh okay well let's do they want to be
blindsided let's do that
okay so there won't be anybody doing
that uh now
would you bring up a good point if the
jury goes into deliberation and wants to
look at some of this evidence
um of course one would
read the law i think nowadays to say
that any scrutiny by the jury
should be
in the presence
of the court here in the courtroom
i very very strongly disagree with that
i think that's antiquated
i think that um
that's based actually on a case i tried
right here that is once again i
i was there
okay so the issue is if the jury wants
to look at testimony or whatever can
they look at it by themselves in the
jury room or do they have to come into
the court dissertation on that but
but
[Music]
that led to i think the anderson case
about showing videos and things
the the law actually developed around
recorded statements of the accused
as opposed to videos of the actual
events
but i think the general rule now is
supposed to be that we're supposed to do
all this under judicial scrutiny could
also say transcript yes permission and
then we have to supervise
one of the things that i find most
offensive is
that um
we've got to scrutinize it to make sure
they don't play it too many times
so they don't over emphasize some aspect
of the evidence i think that's what the
laws what the cases say
and i think how dare
us um
the founders of the constitution
what uh have a juries they have juries
because they don't trust the judges
and the judges have spent the last 225
years returning the compliment
by uh telling
that well always suspecting that the
jurors are going to be up to no good if
this were a bench trial and
like this i watched it how many times
have i watched that video now
and you know what i could sit and i
could watch it maybe 50 more times and
in fact the famous boston
marathon bomber
was resolved because the an agent from
the fbi
watched the video over and over and over
and over again and finally realize what
nobody else had caught which was
that mr zanaya who's now under death
sentence
well
temporarily not
we don't know what the outcome will be
in the supreme court but um uncharged
piccolos
that everybody else was looking one way
and he was looking the other
and it took numerous times looking at
the video to solve that crime
um
so for me to monitor how many times the
jury looks at something i more if we're
a bench trial
and i looked at it a hundred times
and i finally decided i better not look
at it anymore because i might prejudice
myself i get reversed because that's an
absurd thing to say
so i don't want to sit here and monitor
how many times they look at something i
did this guy okay
when the uh when it was attempted murder
case of a police officer and what was
the question
and
they're told they can't even discuss it
with one another
and they can exist and so they're saying
someone should object to this rant and
then i send them upstairs and they're
not looking at it again
and i think that's really frightening
so i think if they want to see the
exhibits we should give them
the equipment to see it and let them do
what they want with it so that's what i
think
now let me hear from you judge i agree
with you that that is antiquated i think
this is the ideal case
where
uh having giving them access or setting
them up somehow with the exhibits uh
would be
uh would be great
um i for i i saw this as a issue i did
ask
people at the department of justice to
look into it not a formal opinion
they indicated they believe it would be
reversible error
i asked even if there was a stipulation
and if the defendant agreed and they
thought it would still be reversible
error under the
uh current law wow and also
and i'm not saying it would be
ineffective but
they thought it would raise an effective
assistance at council claim if there is
a conviction um i i do not want this
case to be a test case uh on
long-established law i agree
that
the the law is antiquated and with the
explosion technology in the last couple
decades it needs to be changed and
perhaps we can do so legislatively but
as it stands now
the state feels that we should follow
the
procedures as
antiquated they may be
defense
i don't want them having a free-for-all
deliberation
okay well i'm not going to cram it down
on this case uh one day one day
uh with a short trial
uh uh
[Music]
um this is crazy it is just absurd it is
uh i agree and i'm the one i guess who's
the dinosaur on
on um on technology but right right i
certainly respect it more than our law
does uncharged
we need to talk about the lesser
included offense instructions mr
um
right now it's the um
the effect of these
right now right now
the charges against you which are stated
in the un amended information counts one
through six
the district attorney has to prove each
of them beyond a reasonable doubt
uh in order to obtain a conviction on
that particular account
and
there's something called lesser included
offenses and i'm sure your lawyers have
discussed it with you
but i want to make sure that you
understand it and i'm required to do
that
and
if the district attorney was not able is
not able to establish your guilt on the
charged offense
beyond a reasonable doubt
then the jury is instructed that they
must acquit you find you not guilty
if a lesser included offense is
presented to the jury
any of the ones we talked about which
are less serious crimes
carrying lesser potential sentences
if i allow those then the jury if they
are unable to agree that you're guilty
of the charge defense will have the
opportunity to consider whether you're
guilty of the less serious offense
and could return that as a verdict as an
alternative to instead returning a
verdict of not guilty
so you were by
having a lesser included offense
included
you're
[Music]
raising the risk of conviction
although you are
you're
there's you're avoiding the possibility
that the jury
will
end up compromising on the more serious
crimes oh my god
and you're also
increasing the up
decreasing the risk that you'll end up
with a second trial because the jury is
unable to agree
any question about any of this so far no
your honor okay
if the jury finds that
none of the crimes charged in the
sequence
charged or submitted
has been proved beyond a reasonable
doubt then they must
put you they must find you not guilty
and they cannot convict you of more than
one crime
on each count
okay yes your honor um
your lawyers have objected to some
of the lesser included offenses
and not others
they have
on some of them they have agreed that
they're appropriate
you don't have to join in that agreement
if you don't want to and you have the
legal right to overrule them
and we'd have to talk more about it if
you decided to do that but you would
have that legal right
and say no no no i want to go to trial
on just the charge offenses all or
nothing
and uh and and
make the decision to force the district
attorney to prove each case beyond a
reasonable doubt that would be your
decision
uh have you had enough time to talk with
your lawyers about this i have have you
enough time to think about what you're
doing yes i have i think what you're
doing is the best thing under all the
circumstances yes has anybody threatened
you or pressured you or forced you in
any way no has anybody promised you
anything in exchange for this no they
haven't is your mind clear today yes are
you feeling all right yes have you ever
been treated for a mental or emotional
disorder
well let me ask you this oh my god
let him answer
for me to be concerned that you
uh
have wow disability
mental or emotional what was that about
prevent you from
being fully aware
of what your options are and making a
rational decision any reason i should be
concerned about that no your honor okay
um any other question anybody wants
asked on this his boss is
was i believe because he's in therapy i
don't think he has a mental illness or
anything okay as a result of this
incident okay he has ptsd okay and that
does but that doesn't affect his
judgment or reasoning power at all
no he's wagging his head no okay
anything else before i accept his
decision on this no
all right um so i'll accept the waiver
and uh and uh
instruct accordingly uh along the lines
that i've already indicated
anything else today
while you were doing the colloquy i
looked at my email i got a
another screenshot of someone saying
they know someone of the jury
i forwarded it along
just for
transparency reasons
to the defense end of the court someone
knows someone on the jury do you guys
know what they're referring to
someone who
i'm disappointed
what
i didn't get it yet um
well wait a minute
someone knows someone on the jury
all right
in other words like a random contact of
one of the prosecutors knows someone on
the jury is that what's being said
um all right thank you
all right well
let's see if there's anything else today
if anybody gets any information about
that whole knows someone on the jury
please email me about it i
just want to be informed about it info
davidpakman.com
so
um
they have finalized
the arguments around
jury instructions
but the judge is
um
still to decide about
exactly what the instructions are going
to be
i want to say thank you to kyle
rottenhaus and brad smith who have just
signed up on my website
joinpakman.com new members 70 and 71.
lawyer violated hipaa revealing therapy
for ptsd lawyer is not a medical
professional so i don't believe that he
can violate hipaa
um
that's my opinion
but people can um
weigh in on that as well
all right everybody whatever you do make
sure you go to the bathroom somewhere
other than the carpool exactly that is
good advice from judge schroeder
do not use the courtroom do not use his
chambers either as a bathroom we will be
back monday
monday we'll be closing arguments
from both sides rebuttal from the
prosecution
jury instructions i think first actually
and then the deliberation will start it
could be hours it could be days it could
be weeks of deliberation we just don't
know we just don't know all right
everybody thank you for joining me thank
you for your
sorry we'll be we'll be back here monday
thank you